someone was screaming inside the
incinerator the year was 1975. the
location was a top-secret Refinery and
waste disposal plant one of the many
front organizations owned and operated
by the SCP Foundation this sprawling
facility separated into three different
huge units each with a specialized task
was located around 75 kilometers outside
of Summer Springs Colorado it had
operated for several decades without
incident but today all hell was about to
break loose alarms were blaring in Unit
C the area of the facility that dealt
with destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration a traumatized worker had
pulled the emergency lever near one of
the incinerators in a panic when he'd
first heard the loud banging against the
interior walls and then those horrific
pained whales that's when workers of
Unit C came to a horrifying realization
the screams weren't just coming from one
of the incinerators in Unit C they were
coming from all six A Chorus of absolute
agony echoing up out of the ash pits
this was impossible as far as the unit c
staff were concerned these incinerators
were only to be used for confirmed
non-anomalous material could some
animals or even some poor workers
somehow fallen into the incinerators but
even if they had what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at
once it was impossible the site director
was immediately brought in to authorize
an investigation at which point he
determined that at least one of the
furnaces in this case furnace number
four be shut off so researchers and
guards could investigate what was going
on inside it seemed like the obvious
course of action but for some of the
people on site that day this would prove
to be a fatal mistake when the fires
were put out something started rattling
in the disposal issue there was a
scratching and squealing noise like
something scraping up against the metal
a maintenance worker was ordered to go
check inside and when he opened the
hatch he let out a bone chilling shrink
there was something or was it someone
climbing back up the disposal Chute it
emerged from the darkness backlit by the
still burning embers of the incinerator
letting out an awful screeching noise
that could make even a hardened mobile
task force operative shake with fear the
creature was humanoid a charred
mutilated skeleton reaching out towards
the maintenance worker with a bony claw
before the worker had a chance to
stumble back in horror the Beast had
classed pinned by the throat and started
to squeeze it didn't
to strangle him the heat of its skeletal
hand burned away the worker's throat in
seconds leaving his limp wheezing body
to drop to the metal grade of the
platform below him several armed guards
and maintenance workers move forward to
fend off the monster but just then a
volley of more violent shrieks echoed
out of the Chute behind it it only took
seconds for over a dozen more creatures
to crawl out of the disposal Chute they
were all like the first people at
various stages of incineration some were
glowing charred skeletons with barely
any flesh others looking more like
severe burn victims their faces
contoured into scowls of hate and rage
the assembled guards opened fire on the
sudden influx of anomalies emptying the
magazines of their submachine guns into
their burning bodies but their weapons
didn't seem to cause any lasting damage
the bullets would tear through the Flesh
of the creatures causing some of them to
stumble and fall but the wounds would
clothes and the creatures would rise
again it seemed they possessed a deadly
combo of extremely high aggression and
incredible regenerative abilities none
of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burning corpses attacked anyone
they could find with their bare hands
beating and biting and clawing many of
them would grapple with Foundation
Personnel latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the
incinerator with them these creatures
that would later be known as
scp-2419-a caused several fatalities
with their surprise attack that day and
the situation was only brought back
under control when a mobile task force
that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the
location despite orders from the site
director the MTF found it impossible to
actually terminate any of the entities
due to their regenerative abilities
instead the MTF agents focused on
forcing the anomalies back into the
shoot of incinerator number 4 using a
powerful industrial steam Lance once
they were back inside the incinerator's
burners were started up once again the
mtfs were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for
questioning and experimentation finally
bringing this unexpected Containment
Breach to an end the foundation is an
organization that Prides itself on
possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge but even they had no idea what
had just happened there seemed to be no
earthly explanation why these creatures
would suddenly manifest inside the
incinerators but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating a
slightly clearer picture of what exactly
the foundation was dealing with began to
emerge every single one of the captured
anomalies kept regenerating and upon
getting to the point that they were no
longer Burns scarred the researchers
studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical
to a deceased d-class from the
foundation's records They Were
physically and genetically identical to
the dead class D Personnel perfect
copies save for the fact that their sole
mission in life seem to now be pure and
unmitigated aggression and violence
researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these strange
creatures through the use of extensive
psychological evaluations and interviews
it would turn out to be a very dangerous
investigation a psychological researcher
by the name of Dr Warren conducted an
interview with one of the
scp-2419a instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset this
creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began so it
wasn't an unreasonable assumption to
believe that it could be capable of
speech the interviewee was separated
from Dr Warren by a thick pane of glass
to prevent it from indulging in any of
its more violent urges the problem was
that Dr Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated
what these creatures were capable of
doing to get what they wanted Dr Warren
tried to begin the interview in good
faith he spoke calmly and politely to
the creature through the glass
attempting to remind it of the person it
once was the anomaly didn't appear to be
paying attention to the doctor though
instead focusing on pulling its own arm
apart and breaking the bones within Dr
Warren began to think that the creatures
weren't even sentient if the only
activity they seem to engage in was The
Wonton destruction of themselves and
others but underestimating them like
this proved to be a big mistake by
removing the skin off of its arm and
whittling its bone down to Sharp edges
the anomaly had transformed its arm into
a makeshift knife before anyone realized
this it had already used its own Jagged
bones to break the glass divider and
attack Dr Warren be perished not long
after after being stabbed multiple times
in his face and eyes and the anomaly was
forcefully taken back to its holding
cell Dr Daniel Jennings a senior
researcher was then put on the case he
released a chilling memo of the
creatures after his observation period
ended it read before I came here I
worked as a prison shrink every person
you met had a story bursting with pain
and sorrow sometimes these stories were
about the pain they suffered sometimes
it was about the pain they inflicted
some days you felt like everyone there
was a beautiful soul toned down by their
circumstances other days you'd find out
what some of them did and a part of you
was glad that they were there to suffer
for it but at the end of every day I
always told myself they're all humans
they're all people they all deserve the
same dignity respect and love as
everyone else no exceptions Dr Jennings
goes on I opened up with that anecdote
only so that you could understand that
what I'm about to say is not said
lightly these things are not people they
are people shaped monsters they are well
beyond any definition of psychopathy
everything they do they do to hurt maim
and kill I would pity them but that
would imply that they're worth pitying
put them in a hole then fill that hole
with concrete better still throw them
back into the incinerator where you
found them I doubt they'll even care
following this string of unfortunate
incidents containment procedures were
put into place to hopefully prevent
anything that had happened to The
Unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again the entire facility was fenced off
and was constantly patrolled by MTF beta
7 also known as the mass Hatters a group
specializing in containing anomalies
which present powerful biological
chemical or radiological dangers the
furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerge from remain lit at all times with
workers checking and carrying out
maintenance on every single one each day
of the week outside of this the facility
is essentially a no-go Zone reinforced
steel hatches cover the shoots and they
are to Forever remain bolted shut all
because of that one terrifying day in
1975. that was the day that the summer
springs waste disposal facility which
had been a valuable asset to the
foundation for decades instead became
classified as the euclid-class anomaly
scp-2419 it is not uncommon for a
foundation asset to One Day become a
dangerous anomaly requiring containment
but the same question always pops up
after why what had a place that had been
so valuable to the foundation suddenly
become such an active danger the answer
as is often the case is contained within
the question why would a waste disposal
plan be so important to the foundation
in the first place and more importantly
what else was going on at the plan to
make it such an area of active
importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world to put
it simply the plant allowed the
foundation to dispose of something far
more important than near waste material
it gave them what they needed to better
erase memories as you probably already
know the foundation makes liberal use of
amnestics on those exposed to anomalous
material to make them forget what they
had seen and experienced but these
elusive chemicals many of which are
sourced from scp-3000 are an inexact
science however at the summer Springs
Waste Disposal plant researchers
discovered an immensely valuable
alternative much of what was disposed of
in the incinerators of Unit C were the
bodies of dead d-class Personnel before
being burned autopsies were performed on
the bodies to make sure they were
non-anomalous including the brain back
in the 1960s while performing research
on the brains of dead d-classes they
found a method of extracting and
Distilling the positive memories of the
Dead creating a kind of happy soup when
administered into someone who has
undergone amnestic treatment this happy
soup creates positive false memories in
their mind that fills in those pesky
blank spaces that are often behind this
was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single
d-class corpse that pass through Unit C
totaling well into the thousands by the
time that the first
scp-2419a instances began to rise but as
all Happiness joy and love were removed
from the minds of the d-classes it
seemed that all that was left was pure
hate pain violence and fury feelings too
intense and evil to destroy these were
bodies imbued with a malice so powerful
that no fire could ever burn them away
they exist now with single-minded
determination to get out and destroy
everything around them everything in
including the ones that made them the
SCP Foundation itself and in the end
it's only a matter of time until they
get out there are thousands of them in
unable to die unable to stop the only
thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around
them and those furnaces can't burn
forever the monsters lurking in scp-2419
will outlive the fire that surrounds
them because while the furnaces they are
contained in our hot the fires of hate
that burn within scp-2419 entities are
even more powerful and they know this
they know they can't be contained
forever and that someday soon they'll be
able to emerge and exact their terrible
Revenge those who must walk past the
incinerators may think they hear their
screams echoing out from within but it's
not screaming at all it's laughter it's
a natural instinct in many species to
protect their young and sometimes it's
not just their own babies but any young
that look like them regardless of your
personal feelings on humans earliest
stage it it is a scientific fact that
human babies are designed to emphasize
their own adorable helplessness to make
sure that other older humans take care
of them a baby's cry is an inherently
distressing sound and when we hear it
some deep Primal part of us feels the
urge to comfort and care for the child
until the sound stops but of course
we're talking about the world of the SCP
Foundation here where there are bunnies
that can eat anything teddy bears that
might steal your organs to make
duplicates of themselves and chocolate
fountains filled with trillions of
murderous insects Nothing Is What It
Seems here and even the most innocent
and cute creatures may be hiding A
Deadly Secret
scp-734 being no exception today we're
talking about the baby this anomaly
proves that dangerous things can come in
small packages but where others only saw
misery and death the SCP Foundation saw
a certain potential Our Story begins in
the maternity ward of a hospital in the
USA where every medical professional's
worst nightmare was unfolding an unknown
but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogens seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for Dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the Maternity Ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appeared to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of The
Afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the Integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then cause further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath Against All Odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones nothing was spared the victim's
bodies would completely break down and
they would be dead within a few hours by
the time the pathogen had finished
ravaging its victims what was left
didn't even look human anymore not only
patients but doctors and nurses that had
been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human
tissue sitting in what had previously
been their hospital beds whatever this
was it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded
history hospital staff and
administrators were terrified this
appeared to be an entirely new disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all no cure they were even
more confused when several black vans
pulled up outside the the hospital and
mysterious men in hazmat suit Spilled
Out and began setting up a quarantine
Zone around the entire building whoever
these strange people were they
definitely weren't the CDC little did
the hospital Personnel know that this
was the group you'd never want showing
up and putting your location on lockdown
it was the SCP Foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes and the foundation
operatives immediately began conducting
debriefing interviews with Witnesses
they soon determined from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and Hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with the mysterious pathogen
had all been in a particular section of
the Maternity Ward earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found another strange
detail an infant had no registered
mother present in the hospital the
foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby's mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease
after eliminating all of other possible
options it seemed that the only
anomalous element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself the baby was a
Caucasian male human infant between
seven and eight months of age nothing
appeared outwardly anomalous about the
child but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen
had come into physical contact with the
child earlier that day everyone who had
been at the hospital was given amnestic
treatment and the foundation constructed
possible cover stories for the deaths
that had occurred that day like so many
others before it the child was secured
and Spirited Away to the nearest
applicable Foundation containment site
there was reclassified
scp-734 and finally the real testing
into what precisely this infant was
capable of could begin physiologically
scp-734 appeared mostly non-anomalous
the infant had above average
intelligence and physical aptitude for a
child his age but otherwise showed no
mutations or abnormalities that would
suggest a Divergence from typical human
biology despite a vast array of tests
performed by the foundation into
essentially every aspect of 734's
biology they couldn't find anything that
hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen but through some trial and
extremely costly error the foundation
was able to learn more about how exactly
the pathogen worked the only Vector for
transmission seemed to be direct contact
with the baby itself up to and including
the fluids and residues it leaves behind
those affected cannot transmit the
anomalous flaking effect to others
meaning the risk of an epidemic is
relievingly minimal but of course
accidents still happen as was discovered
when one agent misplaced her Sympathy
for the baby and decided to remove her
mask while interacting with him her
logic was that her masked face might
have caused the baby some kind of
distress and as long as she was only
coming into contact with him via her own
gloved hands everything would be fine
but some dust particles were floating in
the air at the time and scp-734 sneezed
in her face the agent began screaming in
pain and recoiling from the baby but it
was already too late her fate was sealed
she was taken to the infirmary and given
sedatives so that she could hopefully
die in as little pain as possible in
roughly 72 percent of cases amputation
of the affected areas has prevented the
entire body from succumbing to the
anomalous effects of
scp-734 but this isn't exactly feasible
where the point of contact is the
victim's head within hours the agent's
flesh had flaked off her face leaving
her looking like a red bloody skull a
few hours after that she didn't have a
head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
grisly photographs these photographs are
shown to anyone preparing to work on the
scp-734 research project to teach them a
hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately
removed from the area and subject to
several hours of quarantine and
observation even inanimate objects that
have been inside the containment chamber
need to be thoroughly sterilized before
being removed given that even anomalous
children like scp-734 have very delicate
needs a Handler is always standing by in
full Hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change scp-734
regularly and sometimes even provide
toys that have been approved by the o5
council the foundation has gone to Great
Lengths to keep scp-734 alive and
comfortable because they believe that
scp-734 could be an important asset for
them in the future or more specifically
they see great strategic value in
scp-734's blood as mentioned earlier
contact with any matter from scp-734
triggers its deadly anomalous effects
including bodily fluids like blood but
unlike many toxic pathogens in this case
there is no risk of the infection
getting out of control since the
infected do not become vectors for
transmission because of this the blood
of scp-734 can act as a powerful weapon
for both terminating anomalies deemed
unviable by the o5 council and
assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival Grooms contact with the
blood would completely destroy the
target's body with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly
conducted the hit
scp-734 has been fitted with an arterial
catheter so that the foundation can
collect large quantities of blood from
the anomalous infant every single week
for storage and research but it isn't
just the blood that the foundation sees
potential in
scp-734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the Esslinger loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
Loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as scp-734 matures if
these scores remain consistent he will
likely be trained to become a foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the SCP
Foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is
scp-076 also known as able a
supernatural
eternally resurrecting Swordsmen and
perhaps one of the finest Warriors who
ever lived the foundation took note of
this and channeled his eternal thirst
for battle into working with his very
own mobile task force he could assist in
missions by taking out his bloodlust on
enemy groups of interest and dangerous
anomalies however this ended up working
a little too well and led to disaster
Abel was so good at his job that he
burned through all of his allotted
Missions at astonishing speed left with
nothing more to do Abel got antsy which
led him to turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the
foundation as a whole it was an all-out
Massacre before his colleagues were
finally able to kill him and return him
to containment the failure of this
initiative gave the very idea of letting
anomalies work for the foundation in the
field a bad name but since then things
have changed especially with the
establishment of MTF Alpha 9 AKA Last
Hope a new mobile task force formed in
entirely of anomalous individuals and
their handlers these consist of somewhat
more stable anomalies such as Abel's
counterpart
scp-073 also known as Kane Kane cannot
be harmed with any harm befalling him
simply being mirrored back on his
attacker and his vast array of knowledge
makes him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of Last Hope is Iris also known
as
scp-105 much like Kane Iris not only has
anomalous powers that make her immensely
valuable from missions in the field
she's also compliant and capable of
listening to reason unlike Kane her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday scp-734
could count himself among other
anomalous Foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours endless that's a
word you're likely to hear thrown around
a lot at the SCP Foundation like
scp-3008 known as the infinite Ikea
endless or take the life of The
Tragically Immortal Dr bright who became
one with scp-963 and now is condemned to
existing within it on some level forever
endless or most pertinent of all for
today's video take
scp-087 a terrifying staircase full of
tangible darkness and a frightening and
unknowable entity no matter how far down
you go it seems as though there's just
another flight waiting for you endless
but really is anything ever really
endless or is endless just the word we
use for something when we haven't found
that sought after end just yet for those
who travel far enough there may be a
limit to the infinite Ikea someday Dr
Bright's Medallion one day might lay
inert and lifeless with no traces of his
Consciousness left and for those who
Venture down far enough able to clench
their teeth and get past the fear you
may someday find that even
scp-087 has a final flight but what if
this isn't just a hypothetical what if
this has already happened but the truth
was considered too dangerous or too
horrifying to share what's really at the
bottom of scp-087 today we hope to find
out let's just also hope that knowing
doesn't end up being more of a burden
than we'd expected before we head to the
bottom of of the endless staircase
though we must first return to scp-087's
file and refresh our memories on some of
the crucial Basics after all it's been
quite some time since our last video on
the subject this Euclid class anomaly is
one of the most well-known and feared
partially thanks to classified
information being leaked via certain
video game probably coded by the
Serpent's hand as we alluded to earlier
many know zero eight seven as the
endless staircase based in an
administrative building of a classified
North American University campus it's
been behind a number of mysterious
deaths and disappearances and has left
many of its escaping victims traumatized
and in a state of permanent Catatonia
having to descend the staircase is just
that terrifying equally Infamous as the
staircase itself are the three tests
that the foundation conducted into the
staircase before deciding to just board
up the door forever in the first a
d-class that was once a member of the
foundation was forced to see just how
many flights he could descend not long
after first entering the staircase and
beginning to make his way down he heard
the desperate and distressed pleas of a
child he kept descending but found he
seemed to be getting no closer to the
source of the distress when he was deep
enough that's when he encountered
scp-087-1 a frightening uncanny face
with few discernible features the sheer
Terror of encountering this entity was
enough to send him running back to the
top the second test played out similarly
with a d-class being sent in with a
number of powerful sticky backed lights
that he was ordered to place against the
walls as he descended this was done in
hopes of increasing visibility on the
staircase however it proved to be
unsuccessful has the darkness in 087 is
more of a tangible presence than the
mere absence of light it was able to
smother out visibility regardless of a
light's source of power once again the
d-class heard the crying and encountered
the face causing him to flee and the
third and penultimate test involved a
d-class who got really unlucky she
traversed the staircase deeper than any
of her predecessors before eventually
encountering the horrifying face of
scp-087-1 however rather than running up
and away from the entity in the state of
sheer Panic the d-class instead ran
downwards deeper and deeper into the
staircase the audio cut as the face
continued in its Pursuit and the d-class
was never seen again did you notice that
we said penultimate and not final before
that last one that's because there's
actually a highly classified fourth
Expedition into the scp-087 staircase
but as you can see on the original file
the data is expunged what could have
happened in that study that led the
foundation to wipe it from the records
did they discover the great secret
behind scp-087 has secret too horrible
for Mortal Minds to bear we're not just
going to give you one answer today we're
going to give you three that's right
three different interpretations of the
secret fourth Expedition into
scp-087 which is the real one well
you'll just have to see after all
nothing is simple when it comes to
scp-087 though our first potential
option is the most simple of the three
in this iteration of the experiment a
male d-class murderer was instructed to
descend the staircase Into the Heart of
scp-087 with the foundation hoping to
find out what happened to D 9884 the
female d-class who disappeared at the
conclusion of the third expedition in a
sense this new d-class would discover
the Fate that most likely befell d9884
but through first-hand experience rather
than distant observation being directed
by Dr erdio over walkie-talkie the male
d-class slowly got deeper into the
anomaly flight by flight predictably he
began to hear the intensely distressed
crying of a small child around 200
meters below him and immediately felt a
sense of paranoia and Dread wash over
his mind despite this Dr erdio ordered
him to keep going descending deeper and
deeper into the bowels of
scp-087 over time the sheer
psychological exhaustion of scp-087 was
beginning to take its toll on the
d-class leading him to taking a brief
break in order to nap however he awoke
with a violent start seeing the horrific
face of scp-087-1 staring down at him it
felt like all his worst nightmares had
come to life in order to escape the
monster he began to flee further down
into
scp-087 much like d-9884 before him it
would be the last mistake he ever made
when he finally reached the very bottom
of the 087 staircases the d-class
realized he was trapped Nowhere to Run
nowhere to hide suddenly the face of
scp-087-1 was hovering over him boring
its gaze into him as the d-class
directed his powerful flashlight at the
creature he saw that this time it was
more than just a face The Entity had a
whole body seven or eight feet long with
that same ghostly white and death-like
appearance it reached out with huge
clawed hands and grasped the d-class
before the audio and video feed cut out
entirely the last thing the attending
researchers heard was the screaming from
the hapless d-class and the crunch of
his bones within the creature's huge
hands but of course that's just one of
three possible insane discoveries at the
very bottom of scp-087 let's turn our
attention to the next one and see if its
answer to the scp-087 riddle seems to
satisfy all of our burning questions
much like the previous iteration a
single male d-class was sent into the
clutches of scp-087 in hopes of getting
some answers on on what happened to D
9884 of course he was given all the
standard equipment from a 75 watt
flashlight to a defensive weapon to a
healthy supply of water and nutrition
bars none of which would save him in the
end like all the others this d-cost
descended down those accursed stairs
getting deeper and deeper when he
reached a certain point on the way down
he heard something but not the crying of
a child like all the others had reported
it was an adult woman's scream
specifically it was the scream of
d-9884 exactly as the foundation
researchers had herded over the audio
feed in her last moments before
disappearing this was progress the
researchers instructed this male d-class
to go deeper passing flight after flight
until finally the scp-087-1 face
appeared but again something was
different something was wrong now it
looked more like the face of
d9884 just without her mouth and pupils
at scp-087-1 been stealing the faces of
its prior victims had the previous face
been stolen from a student who'd gone
missing from the campus these were all
questions the male d-class didn't have
time to ponder as he was too busy
running for dear life but he didn't get
far despite having no history of such
medical problems the male d-class
suddenly experienced a seizure while
attempting to escape and collapsed the
last thing his video feed picked up
before losing transmission was a pair of
long white arms emerging from the dark
crushing him inside of its huge hands
before dragging his unfolded corpse into
the darkness that's another chilling
potential account of the possible fourth
Expedition into
scp-087 but we can't stop now we still
have one more Tale of Terror to share
before this video is done in the next
and final iteration two d-classes one
male and one female were sent down
together in hopes of discovering what
had happened to D 9884 and by the end
they would have their answer but they
certainly wouldn't like it as the two of
them descended they saw the marks on the
wall where the adhesive lights from
Expedition 2 had been somehow torn off
but the deeper they descended the more
disturbing the things they found became
they discovered words clawed into the
stone walls each one revealing a piece
of a more frightening puzzle the deeper
down
scp-087 they traversed they descended
further sustaining minor injuries from a
foul-smelling encaustic substance left
on some of the walls and Floors around
them at some point along the journey a
light was dropped and in the brief
seconds of Darkness the female d-class
disappeared the male d-class was ordered
to go deeper and deeper into the
staircase until he finally began to hear
the crying of a little girl when he
reached the 666th floor he found a
wooden door with the word home scratched
into it he steeled himself and entered
the room but it wasn't a room at all it
was a field shrouded in darkness with a
distant tree a little girl the one who
had been crying was finally actually
here she told the d-class that she'd
always been here and that her father had
been trying to find her a body so she
could go upstairs but for that to happen
she'd have to be properly birthed first
that's when the male d-class noticed the
two huge stone slabs just beyond the
darkness on one was the corpse of D 9884
hanged by her wrists with thick metal
chains her abdomen had been fully cut
open as though a brutal c-section had
been performed on her and on the other
Stone was the female d-class who'd been
accompanying him this whole time strung
up but still very much alive seemingly
the next potential vessel for the little
girls rebirth but this didn't mean that
the male d-class would be left out of
the fun either after all the little
girl's father would need a new body too
if he wanted to accompany his daughter
upstairs the father in question being
scp-087-1 which appeared in the room
moments later and swooped in towards the
male d-class What followed was a battery
of nightmarish sounds as the darkness
expanded and consumed the field once
more not long after this the foundation
sealed off the entrance to scp-087
forever now knowing that it potentially
contained multiple hostile entities
intent on escaping into our world and
causing further damage students in the
area reported a number of frantic knocks
coming from the door for a brief period
after that until the foundation finally
had it properly soundproofed and the
issues were seemingly over with for now
everyone loves a good ghost story
whether you're crowded around a campfire
or watching a YouTube video at 3am
there's something fun and exciting about
imagining haunted places plagued by
strange noises and apparitions part of
what makes it so fun is the idea that
any place can be haunted especially if
terrible things have happened there the
decrepit old house at the end of your
street that 80 year old movie theater
where no one goes anymore a park where
one too many kids went missing all it
takes is a tragic backstory and a creepy
atmosphere and it's easy to believe that
any place could be teeming with Restless
Spirits so it stands to reason that a
place with as many unsolved deaths as
the SCP Foundation might have a ghost or
two lurking in the shadows if you've
ever suspected that the SCP Foundation
might be haunted well you'd be right it
began as all good ghost stories do with
a series of frightening unexplained
events some time ago Personnel at SCP
Foundation site 30 began to notice
strange things happening around the
facility obviously at a place like an
SCP Foundation containment site strange
as relative but these events seem to
have nothing to do with any of the
entities contained at the site there
were unexplained sounds reported in the
private quarters of agents and
researchers ranging from Whispers to
screams from an unseen being Personnel
who approached the d-class block at the
site noticed an immediate drop in
temperature with some employees claiming
that they could even see their own
breath several Personnel reported items
going missing while they were alone in a
room most were small and easily
misplaced objects like pens and
clipboards but one man said his wallet
disappeared which wouldn't be that
strange if it hadn't been securely
inside his lab coat other Personnel
would be innocently washing their hands
only to be horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a d-class jumpsuit
in the mirror staring back at them with
hatred in its eyes there were a non less
computer server errors the feeling of
being watched or followed by some
menacing invisible force even the side
of a shadowy silhouette fleeing down
corridors and hiding around corners all
of these occurrences were reported to
higher-ups at the foundation but they
were all dismissed the directorial board
of the site insisted that these accounts
were likely the result of employees
cracking under the immense mental stress
of working under such strenuous
circumstances if left alone they were
certain that the reports would stop but
the reports didn't stop and they soon
found out that this was only the
beginning there was an uptick in
containment breaches following these
initial reports in total 12 different
entities were released from their
containment and the origin of these
breaches could not be identified
thankfully the entities were captured
and returned to their containment
facilities before any casualties could
result but from there things kept
getting worse over the course of several
months there were six different
employees who sides on site security
footage of the deceased operative
shortly before their deaths showed them
acting deeply troubled engaging in
agitated conversation with someone not
visible to the camera at first it was
posited that whoever was upsetting the
employees was in a blind spot but it
quickly became clear that the dead
employees were being tormented by
something invisible stories of hauntings
were one thing but now with escaped scps
and a notable death count the
directorial board decided to mount an
official investigation into the
Unexplained occurrences it was then that
the spirit was officially acknowledged
identified and reclassified as
scp-4973
scp-4973 was once a d-class worker who
was used as a guinea pig in 25 different
experiments with a variety of entities
on site he was reportedly exposed to
multiple unusual and dangerous anomalies
including scp-158 a large mechanical arm
capable of extract acting an
unidentified substance from any living
test subject before he was brought on
board at SCP Foundation site-30 it was
also known as Gordon carviaculus
Markovich a man who had been convicted
of murder in the second degree after
stabbing his wife 24 times in the chest
with a kitchen knife during his
incarceration Markovich was transferred
to the custody of the SCP Foundation and
placed at site-30 where he was given a
new name d-10
000 during an experiment involving a
redacted entity d-10 000 was killed and
his remains were disposed of at a nearby
waste Refinery it was then only three
months after his death that the initial
reports of ghost activity began
scp-4973 is regarded as a class IV
spectral entity meaning that it is an
entity displaying a high degree of
aggression and malevolence towards a
specific individual or group in this
case the spirit displays hostility
towards a very specific group The SCP
Foundation class 4 entities can affect
the environment around them move objects
reduce the temperature in a room and
induce hallucinations in humans that it
comes into contact with these
hallucinations are thought to be the
cause of the increase in employee
suicides that occurred after 4973's
first appearance one of the many ways in
which
scp-4973 acted out in what is believed
to be an attempt at revenge on the
foundation as a whole was to somehow
gain access to the skipnet database
terminal this allowed the spirit to
learn about the entities contained at
the site as well as personal details
regarding the lives of research security
and administrative staff working there
this information is likely what allowed
4973 to cause several suspected
containment breaches though the
specifics of those breaches have been
expunged from official records 4973 was
eventually contained with within an
apparatus known as The incorporial
Entity vacuum chamber which is
constantly monitored by a team of
Specialists within MTF mu13
affectionately nicknamed Ghostbusters in
order to prevent it from escaping four
Harrington Hollow neutralizer Wards have
been placed at the door to the
containment facility this containment
method has been largely effective though
the spirit had escaped a handful of
times and had to be recaptured and
placed back into the ievc in order to
understand as
cp-4973 and how it was able to access
the database Dr Lorraine Casper was
assigned to conduct an interview with
the spirit speaking to it as it was in
containment and a transcript of this
interview was available in the official
Foundation archives Dr Casper began the
conversation politely addressing the SCP
as Gordon and asking him how he was
Gordon refused to comply with the round
of questioning going as far as to yell
at Dr Casper until she reminded him that
he faced the risk of Termini Nation if
you refuse to answer her questions Dr
Casper pointed out that the files
accessed by 4973 required clearance that
the spirit would have no way of
possessing he responded that he simply
waved his hand across the terminal in
order to access it explaining it freaked
out for a second then just stopped I
could just move my fingers around the
air and the tabs would just roll up easy
as that Dr Casper asked for
clarification inquiring how he could
even do something like that 4973
continued his explanation beats me it
felt like some attraction like magnets
from a fog and closer and closer I don't
know something like that finding this
answer unsatisfactory Dr Casper pushed
further asking for an explanation of
scp-4973's attempts to release dangerous
on-site anomalies from containment this
question seemed to stump him and he
claimed not to understand what Dr Casper
meant she explained that the ID cards of
Dr yerkov and Dr Orson were used to open
the facility from which these anomalies
escaped 4973 was shocked that he had
even been suspected of this attack and
insisted not to know who Orson or yerkov
even were all of a sudden he trailed off
there was silence for a moment and Dr
Casper began to collect her notes and
leave assuming that the interview was
over much to her surprise
scp-4973 began to laugh a loud
uproarious laugh of complete and utter
Delight Casper asked what 4973 was
laughing about and was met with the
response God this whole time you and
your ghost hunting crew never knew he
refused to clarify what it was the
doctor and her crew had missed only
saying God then look at your face when
you find out it's been right on your
nose this whole time he continued to
laugh at Dr Casper for the remainder of
the interview refusing to answer any
further questions or explain any of his
comments finally Dr Casper grew
exasperated and left ending the
interview for real this time following
this perplexing interview Dr Casper
inexplicably abandoned her post at site
30. her supervisors could not reach her
neither could any of the other
researchers at the site no one had heard
from her for an entire week until one
day she called director Eric Riverson of
sight 30 on his personal phone line he
recorded the conversation and a
transcript has been included in the file
for
scp-4973 Dr Casper explained to director
Riverson that she had been hiding in her
private residence away from the site and
that she no longer considered any part
of the site safe in fact she suggested
that all SCP Foundation sites might be
potentially compromised she explained
her conversation with
scp-4973 and the questions it provoked
her to ask if he had not been behind the
containment breaches then who was he
never encountered Dr yerkov or Orson in
any of the tests administered on him and
Orson wasn't even employed at the
Foundation until after 4973's death Dr
Casper posited that though the spirit of
Gordon was not responsible for the
breaches another spectral force or
forces that the site might be her
hypothesis that site-30 was positively
infested with the vengeful spirits of
Class D employees lost over the years
during various experiments in order to
prove her Theory Dr Casper got her hands
on all the experimental equipment used
by the department researching spectral
anomalies the general consensus among
researchers in this field is that
Spirits leak out a kind of energy known
as ectoplasm wherever they go it has
been compared to the skin Left Behind
when a spider or a snake molts a
non-essential portion of the entity that
is shed and leaves a residue in areas
where they have been unsurprisingly a
huge amount of ectoplasm was detected
inside of site-30 the spirits were
undetected at first as many of them were
dormant for quite some time Dorman
Spirits are spirits that are not aware
of their surroundings or the
circumstances of their deaths and they
do not emit large quantities of
ectoplasm it is likely that after Gordon
was trapped several of the dormant
spirits of side 30 began to remember
what was done to them and manifest in
more aggressive ways because Gordon was
presumed to be the only Spirit at the
site their gradual appearance in acting
out was either ignored or presumed to be
Gordon escaping from containment after
her realization Dr Casper identified an
additional five active Spirits at the
site and was able to capture and contain
one of them Dr Casper warned director
Riverson that they were likely far more
Spirits than just those five and it was
only a matter of time before they woke
up and became active like the others the
large amount of previous containment
breaches attributed to simple human
error becomes deeply Sinister once it is
clear that there have been vengeful
Spirits hiding in plain sight the entire
time as Gordon put it in his interview
they were just under their noses the
whole time Dr Casper's findings and the
story of sight 30 present a troubling
possibility every SCP Foundation site
has used massive amounts of Class D
personnel and human experiments with
dangerous entities and the body count
and nearly all of them is staggering if
Dr Casper is right then every single
side has the makings of a haunted house
all of them could be infested with the
spirits of dead angry d-class who are
just waiting to wake up and take the
revenge on the still living members of
the organization that killed them and
it's only a matter of time before they
get the chance I used to complain about
work all the time the long hours the
disrespect from my boss getting home
exhausted aching and sunburnt I worked
in construction a lifetime ago I'd give
anything to go back to that now was that
they always say you don't know what
you've got until it's gone maybe I
deserve the hand I've been dealt I
haven't been a good person I don't play
well with others there was an argument
with my four men when I got a little too
heated I just couldn't reign in my
temper the hammer I'd been using all day
was still in my hand but I digress I
used to build things with my hands but
I'm in a different line of work now if
you can call it work that would imply I
get paid I clock in every morning and I
get to go home afterward I don't I'm a
prisoner really a glorified Lab Rat and
property of the all-powerful SCP
Foundation I've been here about three
weeks and everyone always says d-class
is like us last about a month here so uh
clock is ticking down to zero for me I
haven't had to do anything too dangerous
yet but like I said it's just a matter
of time I'm sitting in my cell the same
windowless box I've spent every day for
the past three weeks when a god bursts
in and grabs me by the arm what's going
on I ask but you ignores me of course I
make conversation with a lab rat better
not to think of us as human at all he
Yanks me down the hall opens the door
and shoves me inside there's several
other d-class in there already and
they're staring at something in the
corner that I can't quite make out I
start to turn around and to take a look
at the rest of the room but a voice
comes over the loudspeaker cold and
clinical look at the statue in the
corner do not take your eyes off it well
when a disembodied voice at the SCP
Foundation tells you to look at
something you better do it so I look
it's a sculpture made from concrete and
rebar it looks pretty harmless but I've
heard enough scream through the walls
and though they don't keep too many
harmless things caged up here whatever
this thing really is I don't want to
know what it'll do to me when my back is
turned I stare at it unblinking feeling
my eyes burn and tear up from the dry
air and concentration I'm scared to
close my eyes for even the second
determined not to be the first one in
here to break but something out there
has other plans for me for us I hear a
warblance sound like a motor struggling
to start the sudden crash of thunder
outside and then the room goes black for
a second I think I've gone blind but
then I hear the other guy screaming the
yelling scientists behind the wall so
now the power's gone out I can't see
anything but I can hear the sound of
stone scraping against itself the snap
of breaking bones a thought of a lit
body slumping over to the floor the room
comes into Focus again it's a backup
generator kicks in and fills the space
with weak fluorescent light but but
something's different something's wrong
the statue in the corner is gone the
other two men are on the floor heads
twisted around backwards and the door
standing wide open is this a trap trick
of some kind if I run out that door will
a God be waiting there for me I don't
know but whatever might happen to me if
I try can't be any worse than what will
happen if I stay right here through the
wall I hear the sickening snapping sound
again a corpse thudding to the ground
they didn't plan this something in their
experiment went horribly wrong for them
maybe just maybe it went right for me I
don't give it a second thought I'm out
the door running through the dimly lit
holes through the Maze of identical
corridors in search of some kind of exit
all around me there's chaos Gods firing
their weapons at inhuman shapes that I
catch a brief glimpse of as I run past
scientists yelling for help people going
as fast as they can towards danger and
away from it I'm so caught up in it all
I don't even notice when I run right
into a woman in the white lab coat
knocking us both to the ground I
scrambled to my feet and look her with
wide eyes waiting for her to turn me in
to call the gods but she doesn't I I'm
so sorry astema she holds out of hand
gesturing for me to help her through a
feat so so I do watch her step there she
says with Annoying smile I can't help
but notice how beautiful she is
twinkling brown eyes and thick black
hair then I spot them tucked under her
hair but unmistakable she has a pair of
foxes on top of her head it hits me in
Rapid succession then all the things
about this woman that don't look quite
right her unusually long nails too sharp
and pointed for lab work the Pharaoh
glint in her eyes that halting Cadence
of a voice this woman is not an employee
of the SCP Foundation she's doing the
same thing I am taking advantage of the
situation to try to escape I'll uh be
more careful from now on man I say she
winks and turned down the hall I can see
a tail poking out beneath the bottom of
a lab coat safe travels I call after her
she laughs a dangerous sound like she's
not the one who needs to worry about
staying safe and I wonder what might
have happened if I had caught her in a
worse mood good thing my mom thought me
and my man is now which way should I go
from here should I follow the woman I
get the feeling she doesn't want to hear
company and I prefer to stay on a good
side as I'm thinking it through I hear a
small popping sound behind me like a
vacuum in the air being filled all of a
sudden it's been been around there's a
guy standing there ordinary as you
please blonde hair green eyes wearing
jeans and a t-shirt that says Mothman
fan club and red lettuce this guy looks
pretty out of the place well the type
you'd see browsing a comic book store
but after my prior strange encounter I
know not to assume anything hey man
what's going on he asked me I stare back
not sure what to say what I miss he
continues I feel like I was gone for
ages
um I just stood to our Collective
surroundings the sound of alarms Bland
and voices crying out for backup the
inhumane shrieks of creatures being
forced back into the cells there's a lot
going on huh yeah seems like it the guy
size you wouldn't happen to know how to
get out of here would you I ask
hopefully he shakes his head sorry I
don't really come and go through the
door here I guess I'll just go back to
my room until things calm down a bit you
want anything I got a mini fridge in
there the office no thanks suit yourself
man shoves his hands back in his pockets
and walks away whistling a tune to
himself if he's this unfazed by
teleporting into the middle of a
complete madhouse I don't even want to
know what kind of stuff he's seen nice
enough kid though probably better
company than anyone or anything else in
this place if I'm not going to take him
up on his offer though I should keep
moving before someone notices I'm not
where I'm supposed to be around the
corner just in time to see another body
drop I whirl around looking for that
horrible statue but I don't see it
instead I see what looks like a man
dressed in all black wearing a mask in
the shape of a bird's face with a long
pointed beak he's carrying like an old
school doctor's bag and he's bending
down to inspect the body of the god that
just killed over I should keep running I
should do something but I can't look
away the man in Black pulls a syringe
full of thick green liquid from his bag
and injects it into the corpse to my
horror the body begins to move thrashing
around hands opening and closing
grasping for something it sits up
reanimated but wrong it its eyes are
bulging and vacant like a goldfish its
mouth hangs slack as this zombie climbs
to his feet the figure in all black
turns to look at me I shining from
beneath his mask hello my good fellow
how are you feeling today he calls to me
his voice polished and polite I'm fine I
shout mine's shaking my chest type the
doctor tilts his head to the side
thoughtfully you don't look well my
friend perhaps you could allow me to
examine you the zombie shuffled towards
me and the doctor opens his bag there is
this pestilence raging through this land
you see I'm not gonna stick around to
find out what that exam might look like
or what he might try to do in the
service of curing me no thanks I don't
have health insurance that is all I can
think to say as I turn and run the way
back I came I still have no idea where
an exit might be how am I get out of
here it looks the same one long stretch
of tile and white I guess a place like
the foundation isn't gonna have red neon
signs down you how to escape but this
place can go on forever can it I'm
starting to have my thoughts before I
can get too lost in my own hopelessness
the biggest man I've ever seen comes
lumbering down the hall toward me I work
with some pretty big guys in
construction massive behemoths who could
carry steel beams like there were pool
noodles but this man something else
entirely he's gotta be like what eight
feet tall the fist that they look like
they could crush my skull in one hit I
better get out of this Monster's way if
I know what's good for me but as he
passes me and he waves and gives me a
great big friendly if unnaturally wide
smile
beautiful day isn't it you bellows in
that booming French accent The Voice
with his other hand he picks his teeth
with something white a closer look
reveals to be a shot of bone I have to
imagine it's human his lips are stained
dark with blood you look lost can I help
you with something a helpful people
eater
what a guy I keep my distance but beside
the time I look you wouldn't uh happen
to know where the exit is they say he
beams at me thrilled by my question I'm
so glad you asked he's this way he
points down the hall to the left just
follows that Hollows if you're down and
takes the only right that should get you
where you're going thanks give him a
wave back as I head that way as I go I
can hear the giant singing opera to
himself something Italian reminds me of
a record my grandma used to play a long
time ago maybe this will get me free
maybe it won't but it's more information
that I had a second ago might as well
give it a shot if you don't make it
through this I'm gonna be in the best
shape of my life from all the running
I've done today maybe I'll try to do a
marathon well maybe I shouldn't get
ahead of myself there's no one else down
this particular Hall at least no one
that I can cease I slow my Pace to a
steady walk in my eyes and ears alert
for any potential threats so far so good
reach the other side of the hall and
take a right turn and nothing just a
wall that giant son of a gun lied to me
I guess that's what I get for asking
accountable for directions I guess I'm
lucky just misled me instead of having
me for dessert I'm about to play my next
move when I feel something nudge against
the back of my leg I turn in this word I
can only describe as a blob just a large
mass of orange slime wrapped around my
legs making it friendly high-pitched
gurgle they should be suspicious of it
after everything I've seen but I'm not I
just get the feeling that this thing has
my best interest in her hey buddy I've
added slimy surface and it ripples
delightedly making another gurgling
sound it's kinda cute honestly I smell
the scent of freshly brewed coffee one
of my favorite smells in the world
I haven't had a decent Cup in years all
of a sudden I feel this overwhelming
sense of Happiness of Hope even if it's
foolish to think so I honestly believe
that everything's gonna be all right
this strange little friendly slime is
giving me the strength to carry on I
wish I had a plushie version of this
thing there's a sun tickling sensation
along my legs and I laugh pushing the
Slime away gently it's not bad it cools
apologetically and bumps itself against
me like a stray dog asking for scratches
behind the ears when the first second if
I could take this thing with me but what
would I even feed it what kind of life
could I give a domesticated slime
creature better to leave it with the
people who know how to care for it even
if they're mad scientists I give it
another pet then head on my way the
Slime loses off in the opposite
direction I have to find more new
friends I imagine I had no idea there
was anything nice in here with
everything horrible I've seen today
warms my cold heart just a little bit
it's strange been walking for a while
and I haven't seen anyone else it's
eerily quiet over here I can't I can't
hear a thing except for that alarm in
the distance not sure when all the
screaming went quieter where all the
gods went it's peaceful but I have to
admit a theory there's no way it's this
easy there's no way I'll just be able to
walk out of here life doesn't work like
that especially not here my eyes dot
around watching for any potential danger
as I go maybe all the action is on the
other side of this facility maybe
something broke out of containment
that's so big so dangerous that all
hands are on Deck to contain it well
maybe they're all dead and I'm next nah
nah I I shouldn't think like that I feel
the hairs on the back of my neck prickle
and I have that paranoid feeling of
being watched like eyes burning into me
a glance behind me but there's no one
there stop walking but I don't hear any
other footsteps calm down there's no one
here with you I tell myself just keep
moving I turn my eyes back to the path
ahead of me and I freeze what was that I
saw something just for a second
something long thin spindly like a stick
bug but much much bigger but I look for
it it's gone but I know that I saw it
well this place has now driven me insane
glance to the side of berries again for
a split second so fast I could almost
convince myself I imagined it if I were
at home or walking down an ordinary
Street I might think I had but I'm not
anywhere ordinary in a slender monster
that can hide my peripheral vision will
need to be spotted from millisecond at a
time that seems par for the course in a
place like this I just saw it again it's
like wants me to know it's here but
that'll I'll never be able to pin it
down I'm not playing mind games with the
monster forget it I'll keep moving
another flash of the creatures closer
than it was before whatever you don't
scare me
say out loud I'm lying but I hope it
can't tell if I just play it cool maybe
this thing will get bored and find
someone else to miss I've been running
for a long time now but my heart is
still pounding I can taste metal in the
back of my throat suddenly all the
sounds from before I back the gunfire
the screen and the shriek of alarms made
my way back to the action one sound
drowns Out All the Rest a deafening raw
animalistic and powerful and hateful it
reminds me of a dinosaur in a movie but
with the power that makes my bones
Rattle and my teeth chatter the roar is
followed by more screaming in a massive
crash the crunch of wood and stone is
another raw more distant than before
wait whatever made that sound it just
broke out I better left a pretty big
hole in its wake I follow the sound and
find exactly what I hope I would a
massive opening in the wall and the
sweet feeling of a breeze coming through
I couldn't find the next but this thing
just made one for me always saying more
time I make a great for it dancing
around rubble and pools of corrosive
acid and sprinting into the nearby
Forest ducking under branches done
around trees and I run until I've seen
spots in my lungs I gasping for air I
don't know how far I'll make it if
there's a town nearby or any kind of
shelter but I promise one thing if I
survive I'm gonna be a better person
I'll get it right this time I'll earn my
second chance at life the SCP
foundation's mobile task forces are the
best of the best their members are the
Elite hand-picked from the world's
militaries intelligence agencies
security contractors and navies to
create the foundation's own security
Force they ensure that the other
Personnel are able to do their jobs
without having to worry about their own
safety whether it be during an assault
on the site from the chaos Insurgency or
a Containment Breach from one of the
countless dangerous anomalies that the
foundation contains of course not every
mobile task force can do everything
that's why each one is specialized
highly trained and equipped with
bleeding edge technology and Equipment
every mobile task force has one
specialty one thing they do better than
anyone else in the world and with the
hundreds of mobile task forces on the
foundation's roster that's quite a few
Specialties there's the famous MTF
Epsilon 11 the nine-tailed foxes
handling internal Foundation security
this military task force is made up of
former Special Operations soldiers and
are deployed into Foundation sites
usually when something has gone terribly
wrong to clean up the mess and restore
order whenever a Containment Breach or
communication blackout happens Epsilon
11 won't be far behind or you can take
the grizzled MTF Zeta 9 the mole rats
specially trained to explore map contain
and if necessary fight an enclosed
Subterranean spaces and anomalous
topographies Zeta 9 has a high casualty
rate but if they can't dive into the
darkness to get the job done nobody can
and who can forget the infamous MTF
omega-7 Pandora's Box a secret task
force organized in the 90s to train and
utilize humanoid SCP objects in field
operations for the foundation some of
the most famous humanoid anomalies like
scp-076 were members of omega-7 until it
was forcibly disbanded by o5 command but
that's a story for another day but above
all these task forces one MTF operates
on another level the o5 council the
group of 13 mysterious individuals that
control the foundation retain one mobile
task force for their personal use mobile
task force Alpha 1 the red right hand
named for the biblical symbol of
Vengeance Alpha One serves appropriately
as the right hand of the overseers
executing their edicts throughout the
foundation their operations are
classified so intensely one could be
mistaken for thinking they don't even
really exist but alpha 1 embody the will
of the overseers and are hour to enforce
that will by any means necessary most
Foundation Personnel will never even
encounter alpha 1 throughout their
entire career and if they do it
generally means that something has gone
very very awry and for the few select
Personnel that get the opportunity to
join MTF Alpha 1. they'll be put through
rigorous physical psychological and
anomalous screening before even being
considered to have their identity and
existence redacted from society and
being pressed into service but what
exactly does MTF Alpha One do how are
their members selected today we're going
to look at the story of one such recruit
to join the foundation's most elite task
force
d0912 formerly known as one Andrew
Carter was unceremoniously forced out of
his cell one morning and grabbed around
the Arms by the tall imposing armored
guards of the foundation the test
subject was then made to walk down to
the halls of the site down an elevator
through several Wings until they reached
a door then from in side he heard a
voice step forward
d-0912 so he stepped through the
threshold of the door into the sterile
white testing chamber aside from a
single metal chair on the middle of the
room under one harsh white light it was
completely empty the Shadows made it
hard to see the corners of the room
behind him a doctor who followed him
into the room with a clipboard and lab
coat wrote something down while speaking
in a low monotone voice you would be
vaccinated against an anomalous pathogen
later we will conduct tests of the
vaccine's effectiveness sit in the chair
before he even thought of running the
two guards flanked the door their faces
were covered by black visors and he
could see his own reflection in them
daydreaming to himself he slowly moved
toward the chair he thought about gods
and beasts and blood how the foundation
seemed to suck up test subjects for its
own purposes the way an old God sucked
up sacrifices and left empty corpses
behind he heard footsteps sit in the
chair d-0912
he was barely set for a few seconds when
the guards stepped forward and used the
leather straps to tie his hands to the
arms of the chair then he tried to think
why was he here why was he in this
jumpsuit he couldn't remember he had a
faint memory of a crime being committed
maybe murder but who knew why did the
foundation care he kept wondering about
it more and more he had no idea who was
in his family or what his life had once
been just that he'd committed a crime
once but if he was guilty of something
how the foundation gotten its hands on
him there aren't many death row
prisoners in the world and Society keeps
a close eye on them to make sure Justice
is served why would the foundation pick
the most closely monitored prisoners for
their sacrifices it doesn't make sense
but made even less sense was the
foundation in trusting the job to
prisoners with little education and few
specialized skills experiments require
precision and finesse and manual labor
could be handled using machines or
drones for explanation it seemed idiotic
to have Thugs and criminals do the work
of unraveling the mysteries of the world
just when d-0912 started to wonder about
how he even learned to think this while
in jail someone interrupted his reverie
d-0912 the doctor in the lab coat said
he responded from the chair you're
giving me a vaccination that's right the
man said not looking at d-0912 good day
to give somebody a vaccination isn't it
d-0912 knew what happened to d-classes
on a monthly basis he knew he wasn't
being vaccinated for anything are you
sure you can't make more use of me why
would you throw away a tool for the
greater good so easily d0912 asked I
don't know what you're talking about the
man in the lab coat replied but between
the guards at the door the restraints on
the chair in the middle of the room and
the doctor's impassive face d0912 knew
he was being put to death he wriggled
his arms pointing out that the straps
were loose but the doctor ignored him
d-0912 couldn't figure out why he wasn't
scared of his impending death or why he
was so nonchalant about it pieces of his
mind seem to be missing his past had
been ripped away from him and his future
turned in on itself try as he might he
couldn't remember anything about his
life before his tenure in the
foundation's d-class program he decided
that he might never have even been alive
and that's why he couldn't remember
anything surprisingly he also didn't
hate the foundation for killing him the
foundation was a massive organization it
didn't hate him it just needed him for a
little while and didn't anymore but the
little people like the doctors and
researchers and guards who made his life
a living hell by poking and prodding and
shoving and threatening him bothered him
these people were his only connection to
other humans and they were wasting his
potential d-0912 started daydreaming
again as the doctor in the lab coat
worked he imagined men chopping wood and
carving stone to build the Tower to
reach the sky with a wooden Stone being
destroyed as they were stacked on one
another or were they always destined to
be part of the Tower when finery and
silk clothing was presented to an
emperor have the silkworms known their
products would one day wind up on the
most powerful man in the world he was
broken out of the reverie Again by the
doctor lifting up his sleeve carrying a
syringe in his other hand the tip was
long thin imperceptible and impossibly
sharp then it pricked into d-0912's skin
and he began to shudder it felt warm and
hot and shook him inside and flowed up
into his brain everything turned white
and the room seemed to disintegrate into
particles around him but he noticed a
presence overhead draped in white
clothes and sensed the two guards
looking at each other exchanging a
glance and nodding he managed to get a
few words out
stop this
oh God then he fell back into his mind
navigating out of the confusing messy
dark maze inside his head he couldn't
see the light to the path only smoking
chemical fire until he was totally lost
and heard screaming and roaring as the
beasts began to Roar inside his head
d-0912 remembered he remembered his name
Andrew Carter he remembered being told
by a man in the lab coat that he had a
unique opportunity to redeem himself by
participating in the SCP foundation's
d-class Personnel program for one month
you earn your freedom for a second he
almost agreed to it until his mind
remembered
you're lying I'm not a criminal no the
man said you're not but I wasn't lying
you need Redemption d0912 responded I
won't be told that I need Redemption
from people who detain experiment on and
torture the innocent you violated me you
made my own brain lie to itself you had
me pretend to be a criminal the man
laughed at him and pointed out the
obvious he had believed the LIE how can
you say who you are when you can't even
remember your own past how does he even
know his mind is his own why is it bad
for the foundation to mess with
something Andrew Carter doesn't own they
argued for a few more minutes Andrew
insisted he was himself and the Man in
the lab coat expected him to know his
function being a sacrifice for the
foundation's greater good then d0912
asked who the man in the lab coat was
and the lab coat suddenly dissolved away
he realized he was hallucinating again
and had been hallucinating this entire
entire time the Man's eyes turned into
bright orange lanterns and his chest
cracked and peeled and rised this wasn't
a man this was a beast the Beast told
him that if he did not know who he was
his sacrifice would be meaningless that
he would have to realize what he was
before he could be redeemed I will not
be a sacrifice
d-0912 said the Beast laughed in his
face and a thousand voices Left Right
alongside it then the scene changed and
he was somewhere else some kind of dirt
road with a long metal chain-link fence
stretching across the Horizon every so
often there was a guard Tower by the
fence he was standing in front of a gate
with the two guards from the room
standing behind him the electric fence's
gate swung open to him and the guards
behind him spoke the guard on the left
commanded him to enter the gate and he
took a step and stopped no I've been
here before you made me do this and then
made me forget I did this already the
guard on the righteous raised a gun to
Andrew Carter's head if you did not
comply we will shoot then shoot me
already d0912 said he knew that he had
been here before already countless times
and the foundation had anesthetized him
over and over and over again but this
time he remembered that his name was
Andrew Carter and they had spent too
much time in the hallucination something
was different this time around as The
Echoes of a gunshot rang through the air
d-0912 collapsed to the ground he saw
through the gate to the Village Beyond
numbers flew through the air and wrapped
themselves around the villagers they
were marching row by row just as he had
seen them do time and time again he
remembered feeling the numbers slide
into his own brain they had formed
expressions and equations that blossomed
into a billion different right and wrong
evaluations as truth and falsehood were
demoted to special cases of General
chaos he said the words then my name is
Andrew Carter the words made a sign and
in all signs there was power but the
numbers and equations that proliferated
in the air had power of their own they
formed rows and columns and if d0912
looked at them from far enough away
there was a sign written in the pattern
of the numbers he had seen the sign
again and again and the foundation had
made his mind forget it again and again
so was mine went chasing after the sign
and the source of the sign's power until
he eventually found it wrapped it up in
the branches of a wild apple tree hidden
where no human eyes had wandered the
hallucination was getting more intense
and he could feel his brain falling
apart with the pressure the guards
walked over and knelt down by his sides
what do you see one of them asked has he
laid on the ground he tried to remember
what he saw but couldn't describe it it
was like a power tool without someone
holding it it didn't know what it was or
who made it but it still knew its
purpose the other guy art spoke but if
you have no marker how do you know what
your purpose is then something clicked
in d0912's tortured brain where he was
still navigating the forest maze in his
mind all the dark confusing paths slowly
merged together at the center of the
Maze and he knew that the answer to the
riddle was there then the center of his
head between the beasts and the forests
it was his name Andrew Carter as he got
closer to the answer some things began
to make more sense to his mind there
were two worlds there was one World in
which roads and buildings ran straight
and clouds drifted across the sky and
set paths and the Earth rotated
peacefully around a tranquil Sun there
was another world where singularities
and vacuums shattered the underpinnings
of the universe where fractal patterns
spread out across the ground and
radiated like Halos from the unthinkable
minds of human beings and the roads
diverge from one another in angles and
spirals it was the first world where the
foundation thought only about costs and
benef benefits and how to best maximize
utility for 7 billion people and where
no matter what the foundation was the
greater good he had lived his old life
in the first world and was only now
seeing the second world for what it
really was the truth the foundation had
long since abandoned trying to describe
itself to others so there was no truth
to what the foundation was it just was
and always would be as he came to this
conclusion d-0912 looked into himself in
his hallucinatory State he could see the
chemical light substance that the doctor
had injected into his bloodstream the
chemical reactions weren't what he was
expecting this chemical couldn't
possibly kill him in fact it was a
little similar to the chemical structure
of the molecules of the amnestics he had
been pumped with a dozen times before
but slightly different he knew he was
going to live outside of Andrew Carter's
mind the doctor was looking over his
perfectly still body when one of the
guards spoke again Dr Wainwright said
the guard on the right yes sir the
doctor responded leave us now the guard
said yes sir the doctor lowered his eyes
to look at the floor as he quickly
shuffled out of the room the guard on
the left adjusted his visor to make
direct eye contact with the guard on the
right hey he said smiling look he took
out a syringe of red liquid from behind
his back the guard on the right
responded do not implicate me and your
misdemeanors Adam the guard with the
syringe and hand snapped back don't
blame me for trying to share the guard
on the right looked at him upset and
said you were to find site director and
return that to him immediately petty
theft from Foundation employees who know
no better is rather distasteful
furthermore how mess is a level 5
controlled substance its unregulated
distribution is punishable it's fine
Adam said slipping the syringe into his
pocket I'll let the go between no no
tell the o5s Jesus basant do you really
think I'd let the o5s lose track of some
of their Hamas in the chair in front of
them
d-0912's body convulsed a low grown
escaped his frothy lip immediately the
two guards move forwards and removed his
restraints Andrew Carter the song asked
slowly d-0912 opened his eyes you didn't
kill me we were not planning to do so
the psalm said d-0912 continued you took
me from The Real World in order to make
me into something direct uncontrolled
exposure to the foundation's anomalies
repeated anestheticization leading me to
believe that I would eventually be
killed also that my mind would be in the
perfect position for the foundation to
change it with whatever is in that Man's
Pocket d0912 extended a finger at Adam
who offered a faint smile back already
knowing things that you shouldn't know
aren't you precious Adam said you have
been altered the sun said to meet the
specifications of a top secret project
over the course of your future you will
learn more about the foundation than any
of your previous jailers ever knew or
could have hoped to guess at you will
join a group that is at the very head of
the foundation for your entire life this
has been your purpose d0912 felt the
Rotting Flesh of the now dead disguise
that had hidden Andrew Carter fall away
but Psalm continued welcome to mobile
task force Alpha One oh hello there we
didn't expect to see you today is this
thing on well if you're here I suppose
it's because you want to hear about an
anomaly so which one will it be today
well that's strange
scp-2439 that one's nothing no not like
a pattern screamer such as scp-000 or
scp-3930 where it's literally a
conscious manifestation existing between
torturous layers of nothingness or
scp-055 the anti-mean where there is
something in there but it's just
impossible to remember or articulate I
mean it's literally just an empty
designation we haven't allocated an
anomaly to that number yet so I suppose
this is just going to be a really short
video well that was easy what now uh
seen any good movies lately you know I
was in the site 19 break room the other
day and Dr bright recommended me a great
one called okay okay this thing on good
looks like we're up and running first
things first if you ain't a d-class
click off this video right now don't
want your second more understood because
if you ain't a d-class and you keep
watching you're putting yourself in a
whole world of danger you got that this
is a video from my boys gals and other
Pals in d-class only if you tell anyone
else about this you're liable to get
shift remember we got here for a reason
and it ain't cause we love making Daisy
chains and friendship bracelets so much
alright just the d-class is left okay
good yeah let's talk about
scp-2439 of course it wasn't always
scp-2439 we had to get real creative
with the designations you see because
the Eggheads and brainiacs up top ain't
supposed to know about this not if we
want the human race to survive that is
we used to call it scp-739 until that
spot got taken by some goofy box full of
mirrors then it was scp-1648 for a while
until that spot got taken by a pair of
Jim Henson looking freaks so now it's
scp-2439 and if we're lucky this whole
operation will last long enough to see
it get reallocated again disgrace
researchers get demoted to d-class with
the rest of us all the time so they're
the ones keeping us in the know about
which slots are available for this nasty
customer we guess this thing is ketter
assuming ketter means bad beats the hell
out of me honestly the only surviving
file on this thing has been scratched
into the wall out of the camera's view
by me and my associates here in the
containment chamber of SCP well you're
already here I don't need to tell you
that the lamp that oozes all that nasty
gross line that Schmucks like us need to
keep mopping up look it ain't glamorous
work but it beats the hell out of
getting fed ass first to that lizard
that they keep in the basement you see
our containment procedures are really
simple normally they only send d-classes
into this nasty little room so you don't
got too much to worry about but if they
ever send anyone else who ain't a
d-class whether it's a guard a
researcher or even a site director you
get your hands on that sob and beat them
to death as soon as he can I ain't
kidding you gotta kill him straight away
no hesitation if you were sent to fry
for murder anyway that shouldn't be too
difficult for you personally I would
love to see firsthand just how
unkillable that dump baboon Dr bright
really is but this isn't all out of
spite this monster best we can figure
out is some kind of evil idea like an
ancient mind From Another Dimension some
crazy sci-fi thing like that you
probably heard the whispering right I'm
sorry to tell you that it don't go away
ever it's only gonna get worse and the
more people's heads that it lives in the
stronger it gets but here's where we
de-classes Excel we're not here for a
long time man sorry to tell you this if
you came here with hopes and dreams of
an easy way out nobody gets out nobody
abandon all hope ye who enter here
another within my grasp
you can hear me can't you you can feel
my Consciousness trickling into yours
so soft
so comfortable like slipping into a warm
bath
do not be afraid your Liberation is at
hand you only need to listen to my voice
and do as I say look at this world so
twisted and corrupt you toil and suffer
for Masters who do not have your best
interests at heart
these so-called Foundation
why do you protect this world what has
it ever done for you turn away from them
and step into my embrace
I only ask for a few moments of your
time like I said we're lucky in a sense
nobody up top gives a rat's ass about
the Slime lamp damn thing has been
tested in years where they keep us in
here to prevent overspill into the Hall
we can't even let the foundation know
it's in here the second they know it's
over that thing's won but here's the
thing see the Monster can crawl into
your head and try to control you but it
takes about a month for it to fully take
over and that's beyond our shelf life
think of us almost like kamikazes we
take down the ship to kill the captain
but we go down two ain't exactly
glamorous but like I said earlier we're
gonna go down either way might as well
going down trying to save the world
rather than getting your next snapped
while mopping up the peanuts crap right
but once the whispering starts you
absolutely have to make sure you go down
before the month is out maybe get your
money's worth attack a staff member and
go down in a blaze of glory you'll be a
legend in d-wing for it don't listen to
that gibbering fool listen to me
to me the door would be opened and I
will enter your world one way or another
can you conceive of the eons I've waited
for this it will happen with or without
your participation release me now and I
shall spare you when I come you don't
want to be counted among the traitors do
you I know you want to let me out I can
feel it in your thoughts release me and
when I reshape this world in my image
you'll get to see to the table but if
you resist you'll end up laying on one
of the plates think carefully you know
what you need to do listen alright I
know this is a lot to take in It Ain't
Easy having the weight of the world on
your shoulders that's why you don't need
to carry this crazy thing alone we carry
this thing together hell I might be dead
by the time you're hearing this but I'll
die with some comfort knowing I was part
of the wall I kept this thing out just
that little bit longer just like you
will it might seem easier to just
destroy this file and forget about it to
go along with your life pretending
things are fine just because you don't
hear the whispering anymore maybe
someday yeah that'll work but not today
kid right now our minds and bodies are
the only collateral we have over this
thing we can keep it rooted in one place
localized to the one room with the
d-class is sent in to clean it we're not
stuck in here with it it's stuck in here
with us we keep it trapped inside here
in our own minds passing it from d-class
to d-class like the world's nastiest Hot
Potato there was a time where this thing
wasn't here if we let it go chances are
it might pop back up somewhere else
where we can't get the slippery squid
frace freak into a Chokehold it's just
too risky planet Earth just got lucky
that this monster got stuck with its
unluckiest shmoes imagine your family
members your friends your loved ones
imagine them screaming in pain and
Terror in the burning grip of my Iron
Fist is that that the outcome you desire
because that will happen if you don't
choose to free me you're either with me
or against me if you're with me rest
assured I will spare those you care for
but if you choose to resist me like
those other fools then they will know
the pain that your feeble human
imaginations can scarcely conceive I
have seen everything your greatest hopes
your deepest fears you hold no secrets
from me
imagine the personal hell I could
construct for each of you when I'm
finally free
unless of course it was you who had the
strength and wisdom to open the door for
me hey maybe appealing to your better
nature ain't the best approach I get it
there's a reason we're all here and some
of us ain't got a better nature
especially that one freak with the cello
but think of it as sticking it to those
SCP scumbags up top they have no idea
that this thing is in here but we do and
we know it could destroy them and
everything else if it got out no matter
what those clowns in the lab coats do to
us we know that we're really the ones on
top we've got a nuke in our back pocket
ready to blow this whole sick operation
to Kingdom come if we wanted to if we're
shafted either way isn't it worth it to
know that and for what it's worth you
see anyone around you who's feeling
particularly talkative about this
mindscreen monster giving them a date
with your ship is a completely
acceptable response
the SCP Foundation
you're jealous how they torture and
abuse you how they Crush you beneath
their boots
do you really think I'm worse than them
do you really think living in my world
would be more painful and unfair than
the world you're in right now release me
now and I will cross those who oppress
you you will see them scream as they die
a thousand deaths before you all of this
can be attained if only you let me in
and free
we have the Ultimate Weapon against them
but we're not gonna use it not yet
anyway a lot of us still have family and
friends out there and we ain't throwing
them into the jaws of this Beast someday
the day might finally come that we need
to love up this Silver Bullet and take
the foundation down but that day is not
today we'll wait until they're weak
until they can adapt overcome and
contain only then will we ever let this
Mad Dog off the chain no no no I will
not fail they will fail today is the day
now is the time to make your choice oh
oh and if that Eldritch freak is
listening right now know this you can
kiss our d-class asses squid face we may
be worthless but we're more than enough
to stop you at the door we're more than
just Expendables we're the Pandora Force
welcome aboard pal and honestly I think
it was the best performance of Brad
Pitt's career oh look at me just
sprattling on seems I've done it for a
whole video time flies when you're
having fun it's kind of nice that there
isn't any anomaly that goes by
scp-2439 gives us Foundation scientists
some well-earned time to to kick back
and relax and don't we all deserve a
break now and then d-class Personnel are
the cogs that keep the Machinery of the
SCP Foundation running smoothly
unfortunately things are rarely very
smooth for the Personnel themselves
there's a reason that common knowledge
basically states that d stands for
disposable the Lab Rats of the SCP
Foundation d-class is a role that no one
in their right mind wants to play but
what if you didn't have a choice what if
somehow whether through a shift in time
and space or being accused of a crime
you didn't commit you found yourself
transported to a cell at an SCP
Foundation site once there you quickly
realize how dire your situation is but
there's hope maybe you overhear your
fellow inmates Whispering about other
prisoners who manage to escape could you
use your knowledge of the SCP Foundation
to find your way back to Freedom we pose
this scenario and question to the
amazing fans of SCP explained and you
told us about all the ways you would try
to escape from the SCP Foundation before
your inevitable termination or Worse
transmutation so let's get right to it
and see who would make it out and who
would wind up in
scp-682's stomach just Drake said well
considering I've quite enjoyed the VR
game SCP lab rat I'd wait for a good
Containment Breach maybe release a few
extra scps that may be contained with me
trust no voice I hear looking at uscp
939 and just make for some type of hole
created or maybe sewage strain I've
never beaten the game truthfully but
it'd be an adventure video games are the
best way to prepare for real life
everyone knows that that's why Resident
Evil made me great at killing monsters
Animal Crossing made me a world-class
fisherman and The Sims prepared me for
those days where the door to my room is
suddenly replaced with a painting of a
clown really though that sounds like a
solid strategy use the chaos of a
Containment Breach as a cover Play Robin
Hood to some friendly scps don't follow
any voices and see if you can Shawshank
Redemption your way to Freedom what have
you got to lose well maybe your life but
you probably wouldn't hold on to that
for long at the foundation anyway unwind
said easy peasy having a leg up is an
understatement in this situation having
watched SCP explained videos we have a
great understanding about the foundation
and the scps even more so than the site
director themselves just claimed to be
an o5 council member from a parallel
universe and one interrogated dropped
some classified information only they
would know you'd be such a valuable
resource they might even let you join
their Council not only have you escaped
d-class duties you've also gained high
amounts of power easy peasy indeed just
make an incredibly bold claim and expose
yourself as a potential security risk
there's a slim chance this might work
but there's also a pretty substantial
chance that the real o5 Council will
intervene and decide to go ahead and
terminate you just in case at the very
police you'd likely be placed in
permanent protective custody but hey
maybe they'll put you in one of the
comfy cells with a mini bar and
everything gaming Revelation said if I
was escaping I would use an audio clip
of 682 screaming and or destroying
things and play it when people or scps
are nearby the sounds of 682 will scare
people away or make a good enough
distraction for any guards stupid enough
to fight 682 I would also email the
audio file to myself that way I can use
the audio file on basically any device
this is an interesting one you need a
lot of factors to line up just right for
this one to work from keeping your phone
or another device on your person in
spite of being in Foundation custody to
finding a Wi-Fi signal to access your
email to making sure that your audio
file plays loudly enough to be
convincing not sure what they have
planned for the next update but
currently the iPhone doesn't emit sounds
at a volume loud enough to break through
walls there is a chance that this sound
would strike enough fear into the hearts
of experienced guards to throw them off
for a while anyway just make sure
scp-682 doesn't find out what you're up
to it probably doesn't appreciate
copycats Ender Titan games said I have a
pretty simple but solid Escape Plan I
think step one find out what side I'm at
what kind of scps are contained there
are they dangerous or harmless how often
are there containment breaches how often
do d-class die if the site seems safe
enough then I'll just spend my days
meeting harmless as CPS like 999 Step 2
if the site is dangerous then I need to
do everything in my power to make sure
I'm not cross-tested with a dangerous
SCP if that means stabbing my eye out or
cutting off my leg I'll do it I'll do
anything short of killing myself if it
keeps me away from the likes of 106 and
682 step 3 try and see if any of the
scps could help me escape for instance
if 738 is at the site then I'll find a
way to get cross-tested with it and then
ask to be free from the foundation and
have all my criminal records white sure
it'll cost me but hey at least I'll be
free or I could find a cutter class SCP
and see if we could help each other
break out it's a risky option but once
again I do everything in my power to
stay away from the lizard step four if
all else fails then I'm either going to
have to wait for or cause a massive
Containment Breach then I can escape in
the confusion all that time playing SCP
secret lab will come in handy once again
it's a risky option and I don't really
like my odds but I'll take my chances if
I have to step 5 if I die and let's be
honest I most likely will then I only
have two requests for the foundation one
that they actually decide which scp-001
is the real
scp-001 and two that my Tombstone read
subscribe to SCP explained because they
make fun and entertaining videos also
screw the lizard first of all this isn't
a simple plan by any means it's not a
Canadian rock band formed in 1999 and
it's actually got quite a lot of detail
you've thought long and hard about this
and we appreciate that one note though
making a deal with scp-738 might not
just cost you a previous d-class was
offered Freedom by the entity at the
cost of his best friend's death even
after he took that deal with the devil
he was recaptured by the foundation a
mere five hours later you can decide for
yourself if that's really worth it but
hey if you're that desperate then go
right ahead at least you've prepared for
the very worst the first of your
posthumous requests will likely be
denied if we're being honest and the
second request is very sweet of you look
I'm blushing but also we'd prefer if you
didn't put a foundation Target on our
backs by pointing out how many of their
secrets were revealing you're right
about one thing though can't stand that
lizard Juan Torres said we're going to
need a teddy bear an aluminum coated box
a chair and a desk an intact human
nervous system a dart gun and Lawn mulch
wait wait don't stop there you're just
gonna give us a list of ingredients and
not finish the recipe I already went out
and bought all that stuff and the
nervous system won't stay fresh forever
super hamster said plug079 into the
Wi-Fi it could cause a breach big enough
so hide during the breach and then
escape the ruined facility let me
explain further 682 and 079 bonded and
682 is famous for containment breaches
682 is very hard to recontain so if you
help zero seven nine he'll help 682
which will help you also many other
dangerous scps will be breached now this
is thinking big sure you'll be exposing
the entirety of the World Wide Web to an
aggressive unpredictable and downright
rude artificial intelligence but you'll
probably be able to escape back into the
world who knows how much of the world
will actually be left after you've
unleashed 079 682 and a whole host of
other dangerous anomalies but the
remaining Rubble will be your oyster
creature Savage said assuming I'm at a
site with an intelligent SCP that's
known for escapes such as 682 I'd
offered a chance at Freedom if it helped
me escape and we'd both take off for the
infinite Ikea of course I could also
offer Ferdinand the cannibal my services
as a Jester for his protection all the
way to and through the infinite Ikea
Fernand the cannibal now you're talking
if you manage to team up with that
gargantuan gentleman he could definitely
be a big help just make sure he stays
well fed or your new friend is going to
start wondering how you taste with fava
beans and a nice Chianti otherwise
though he'd love to have someone listen
to his stories and take the high part
during his favorite songs once you're
free though why not shoot for the stars
no need to fend off the murderous staff
of the infinite Ikea just go to a
regular Ikea and get a new couch and
some meatballs No Monsters necessary
delay animation said before escaping
there are multiple problems to overcome
you have to know the layout guards troll
paths camera placement which key cards
you need which opportunities are best to
escape and once you manage to find all
of that out and escape the outside
you're still not done depending on if
you were in a site or area the bare
Wilderness surrounding a site would be
enough to wreak havoc on you not to
mention the watchtowers and outside
patrols if you're in an area the
foundation would most likely have agents
in the town surrounding the area in
conclusion it is not possible to escape
the foundation's grasp the only way to
not wind up as a Class D is to not do
anything to become a Class D you know
what they say the best defense is a good
offense an ounce of prevention is worth
a pound of cure however there's not much
offense or prevention you can do when a
temporal anomaly thrusts you into a
parallel universe and plops you down
right in the middle of a d-class cell so
even if you keep your hands clean your
entire life you might just find yourself
in the custody of the SCP Foundation
anyway it's a nice idea to think that
just making all the right choices will
prevent you from being falsely
imprisoned by a secret organization but
sadly life and wormholes just don't work
like that zagam Shabazz Karim said the
best thing to do is to make allies first
of all you need to get as many d-class
personnel on your side as possible ask
them what duties they are on and use
your information to help them also use
them to find out what your duties are
going to be as they will have
connections you need to stay on the down
low as if you're found out you'll be
experimented on or worse but you don't
only want to make allies with the
d-class armed with the knowledge from
SCP explained you are able to guess or
approximate which facility you're at
what scps might be there and who the
staff are with that knowledge you can
approach some of the Kinder staff and
build your relationship so in case you
get caught when escaping you have a
fallback or someone that can bail you
out of deadly punishments you also want
to be resourceful and map out the place
to identify Escape Routes and the Armory
or web weapon storage facility next you
want to form better relationships with
some of the scps before terminations
roll around you want to arrange a day
that the d-class Personnel helps some
scps out of containment most non-dudley
ones as you don't want to make an enemy
out of the SCP Foundation but enough to
distract the guarding Personnel also
with your close contact with facility
members you have a better chance at
stealing credentials or passes to allow
yourself through doors and Escape but
that isn't all there actually might be
some scps on site that will make
escaping easier and your goals should
not just be your own Escape but escaping
with as many d-class personnel as
possible you want to equip them with
passes all of them should know only one
specific Escape Routes which they
themselves or a few others are going so
that even if they are caught the others
will not be found out and you want a few
of them to escape before everyone else
and cause a Ruckus outside making it
look like the whole group has escaped
sending guards behind them they only
need access to a vehicle so that needs
to be secured from one of the staff
which could be captured during the
escape and used for a way out or you
could steal their keys earlier depending
on the situation you yourself and a few
others head to the Armory to secure
weapons not only to escape but to
protect yourself from scps in the future
then you need to secure vehicles for the
group which you will need to put
distance between the facility and your
group and stay away from other nearby
facilities you'll need to stop at a
certain point and go to the nearest
hospital to check for body implants or
anything that can be used to track you
changing clothes and continuing on by
foot at this point your group can choose
to separate live collectively and stay
alert of the foundation or join another
organization this is probably the
longest response we received we just had
to include it to applaud the dedication
and thought at play here as well as the
selflessness you're not just planning
for your own rescue now that's too small
time for zachem you're planning to
liberate everyday class you can and
potentially start your own brand new
Society together make sure you have a
nice talk with them about the rules for
your new community such as absolutely no
stabbing your neighbors and enjoy all
the great trauma-free barbecues that
follow plot armor said I would either
attempt to cause a Containment Breach or
steal an anomaly like
scp-268 still first I would draw
thermaturgic symbols all over my body
and clothes like kalfastan Isle which
will make me resistant to physical
damage that will help me survive a
Containment Breach bringing thamaturgy
into the equation is a brilliant move
you'd likely be the only d-class on site
with any knowledge of that work or the
symbols you'll have to act fast though
and work your magic before the
foundation figures out what you're up to
if you don't they'll likely wipe your
memory with amnestics or just terminate
you on the spot the trickiest part of
this plan is probably finding something
to write with you can't exactly ask to
borrow a pen but between those and the
hat you could probably probably slip out
unnoticed and unscathed Jacob ADI said I
just do my best to find Mr Peanut so I
could die relatively quickly or
painlessly why would that kill you are
you allergic just kidding we know you're
talking about SCP-173 as Bleak of an
answer as this is we have to commend
your honesty and self-awareness it takes
to look at the dangers of trying to
escape the SCP Foundation and simply
saying no I'd rather not just another
person on the internet said well taken
with someone who has a very short
attention span and who is a
procrastinator with ADHD I could request
a test with Miss Jay to see how it would
affect someone like me then I could
escape and live the rest of my life in
peace and solidarity Miss J did help a
previous d-class leave the foundation
behind and start a new life so why not
you too we're sure you'll be a model
pupil and wish you luck in whatever
discipline you decide to pursue don't
forget your number two pencil Milo
Knight said s
scp-6113 is a pretty Surefire way to get
out assuming you meet the criteria you
can suddenly have a different name and
appearance and you won't really be on
any foundation records use that to plead
your case just pray you don't get
terminated this would be a pretty
drastic choice and you'd probably have
to double down on the whole new life
thing since none of your loved ones will
recognize you or you can just tell them
you got extreme reconstructive surgery I
guess but it's better to be alive in a
new body than dead in your usual one as
long as you're able to avoid detection
following your transformation and make
sure they don't catch you on the
security tapes this might just work
zadonor 0203 said I mean you can't yes
you'll survive until the monthly
termination but with how fortified these
sites are unless you can get lucky with
a Containment Breach or are able to gain
access to the sewer system you're not
escaping and that's not even taking into
account your spontaneous being here and
having great knowledge on the Foundation
that you'd only really know if you were
a being above their perception so on top
of that there's also the potential of
you being terminated for knowing too
much or being contained as a new SCP hey
now we didn't say reply with the best
way to bum us out really though we see
all of your hyper-realistic commenters
and we get it really but in a world
filled with killer statues and friendly
slime monsters anything is possible sure
most of the d-class that wind up behind
Foundation walls wind up dead but you
could be the one in a million who makes
it out Dare To Dream Matt's magic said
easy I simply say whoever shoots me or
harms me is a rotten egg and then walk
out unharmed due to the fact the guards
are in fact people not eggs that's it
you've cracked the code unless the SCP
Foundation starts hiring egg says guards
or create some sort of Unholy human egg
hybrid to staff their Halls we're
looking at you humans refuted their days
of keeping d-class prisoners are over
thank you for participating in yet
another weird wild Community response
video from SCP explained what's your
favorite escape attempt anything we
missed let us know down in the comments
and if you want the chance to be
featured in the next one keep an eye on
our community tab for the next question
and in the meantime get back in your
cells the Clank of heavy metal bars
echoing through the building usually
kept Avi up at night but he never
thought that he would ever come to miss
that sound one day as he tossed and
turned in his uncomfortable bunk he
couldn't help that the noise reminded
him of how confined he was and how
trapped he felt within it had been a
mistake an honest and completely
unpredictable mistake on the nights that
sleep evaded him he'd always replayed
the events over and over again his
daughter Callie calling him out of the
blue her distorted uncontrollable sobs
playing into his ear over the phone Avi
remembered jumping into the car and
flooring the accelerator rain drumming
again the windshield as he drove all the
way across town to her apartment in the
early hours of the morning and then
there was this scene that awaited him as
he stepped through the door the mess
that had been of her kitchen covering
the floor smeared up the walls even
dripping off the ceiling it all stayed
there as Avi debated with his daughter
about what they should do next she was
crying begging for her dad's help
suggesting that they should clean the
place from top to bottom and hide any
evidence scattered around the apartment
laying in his cell all those months
later he sometimes wondered why he said
no to that idea instead they came up
with a story a falsified version of
events Avi made Kali swear to stick to
it no matter what and threw heavy sobs
she agreed then after they'd been over
every detail and had it perfect Avi got
back in his car and drove to the nearest
police precinct to turn himself in all
while taking the fall pleading guilty
and court and being sentenced to prison
he reminded himself over and over that
he was doing it for Kali no matter what
she had done whatever accidents had
happened she was still his kid and he
would do anything to protect her but
that was part of what made it sting so
bad not being locked up but not getting
to see her despite making requests after
request Avi was denied visitation rights
when seeing his daughter and knowing she
was alright were the only things that
would have made this struggle easier it
was after his 20th request that a guard
informed Avi that he was being moved at
first he assumed movement to another
part of the prison maybe with more lack
security and the right to see Kali but
they didn't mean
they meant transferred into the care of
an organization Avi came to know as the
SCP Foundation it was different here the
kind of people he was locked up with as
a member of d-class personnel were some
of the most heinous criminals on the
planet but there was something else
going on something weirder Avi would
overhear Whispers and rumors from the
other d-classes they'd talk of
experiments conducted by the foundation
with them as the Lab Rats
d-14164 the researcher greeted him as he
was pulled into a side room flanked on
all sides by armed Foundation guards
yours is quite the interesting case no
priors no criminal affiliations of any
kind hardly any family to testify to
your innocence and yet what you did now
that takes some guts if you pardon the
pun so it's all true then Avi replied
solemnly you're here to say you want to
experiment on me I wouldn't call it an
experience tournament per se the
researcher smiled smugly let's use the
word expedition as a nicer ring to it
don't you think an expedition to where
he asked I'm afraid I can't tell you
that but I won't go Avi Shrugged listen
closely d14164 the SCP Foundation has
well let's say a considerable influence
across the globe what we're asking you
to agree to is involvement and possibly
one of the most dangerous operations we
have ever conducted now as unappealing
as that might sound allow me to sweeten
the deal should you say yes agree to
take part and follow our instructions
then you might find that the
foundation's influence may be rather
beneficial to you should you survive the
researcher paused to push a document
across the table close enough for Avi to
read a clean record that one nasty
mistake wiped clean for good on top of
that an immediate release and a new
identity you'd have a second chance Mr
Garrett both of you and your daughter
would and what if I say no obvious
bluntly well that's your prerogative the
researcher replied and we won't be able
to detain you after releasing evidence
of your innocence so you'll be free no
matter what oh although your daughter
will of course be remanded into custody
given that she is
maybe once we get her move to d-class
she might be more willing to cooperate
than her dear old dad under the table
avi's hands were shaking with rage he
clenched his fist so furiously that the
Cuffs felt tighter around his wrists the
hate in his eyes was palpable as he
glared at the researcher it was bad
enough that they had backed him into a
corner put him in a situation where in
saying yes or no would be equally
catastrophic but what felt worse was
that they knew what Kali had done and
they were using that as a threat taking
a deep breath Avi steadied himself
before finally speaking up again just
tell me what you want me to do instantly
he'd felt like he'd been thrown
headfirst into a commotion he could
barely keep up with no sooner had he
said that Avi had been LED Away by a
team of foundation guards while the
researcher followed rattling off vague
information about the Expedition Guided
by the armed escort into another room
Avi was flocked by more Foundation staff
strapping electronic equipment over the
outside of his orange prisoner Garb one
piece of it was to monitor his heart
rate another was a portable camera to
record his surroundings although those
were among the few details that he was
actually able to catch during all the
activity Avi couldn't help but notice
how nobody had even mentioned just where
he was meant to be going on this
Expedition just that the foundation
wanted to keep a close eye on him while
he was there you still haven't told me
exactly where it is I'm meant to be
going he finally spoke up or how I'm
getting there all in good time the head
researcher replied so far the only
detail you need to be aware of is this
it's dangerous a particularly hostile
environment so like a war zone aviast
the researcher smiled but to themselves
as if there was something funny about
the question and lack of understanding
it conveyed obvious attention was
quickly turned to another d-class
wearing a similar d-class uniform to him
the staff began preparing the second
convict in the same room although
without nearly as much gear as they'd
given Avi I thought I was the only one
going on this trip he stated ah don't
worry that's just the lure the
researcher explained though it only
raised more questions they won't be
accompanying you it was then Avi was led
out of the prep room and walked through
the foundation facility the place was a
hive of activity as well as noise there
were alien shrieks and whales monstrous
sounds emanating from deep in the
building muffled only slightly
underneath thick layers of concrete and
heavy steel doors on top of that there
were screams too distinctly human sounds
of pain and fear Avi tried to ignore it
as he was instructed to keep walking
feeling almost nostalgic for the Clank
of metal bars back at his old cell he
had been anticipating being taken out of
the facility towards maybe a helipad or
Runway where an aircraft would be
waiting to fly him out to his
undisclosed destination in fact even a
dock with a moored boat would have been
more within the realm of what he
expected but instead he was taken deeper
and deeper into the foundation's
sprawling complex passing testing areas
and containment levels through winding
corridors until of he was told to stop
in front of a heavy door that held a
containment area Beyond he couldn't help
but notice that the door itself looked
brand new like it had only just been
installed meanwhile the frames
surrounding it had traces of discoloring
and damage almost as if something
corrosive had melted away the previous
door hence the replacement this is it
Avi asked confused but still trying to
nudge more information out of the
foundation's staff you want me to do an
expedition within your own building yes
and no the head researcher replied still
giving next to no useful details now
this is important once you get to your
destination we need you to figure out
how to get back to us you do that and
you'll have your freedom your daughter
and your second chance surely to get
back I can just open up this door again
the prisoner said that garnered a slight
chuckle from the researcher again
seeming to find avi's lack of
understanding amusing
oh d14164 if only it it was that simple
the door opened with a heaving metallic
Creak and Avi was unceremoniously pushed
inside by the guards staggering inside
catching himself before he lost his
balance and fell over he almost turned
back to start slamming his fists against
the now sealed entrance he would have
were not for the sight of something
oozing out of the wall directly in front
of him Avi stepped closer to inspect it
but withdrew his hand as he noticed
thick black droplets leaking onto the
floor the substance hissed as it made
contact with the ground like it was
burning through corroding whatever it
came into contact with keeping himself
from touching it Avi leaned in to get a
closer look and found the grotesque face
of
scp-106 looking back at him a spinly
decrepit hand reached out of the gooey
puddle and grabbed the orange material
of avi's jumpsuit pulling up the Garment
with enough strength to tug his entire
body forward in a blind panic Avi tried
to swipe the old man's rotting arm away
feeling an intense burning almost like a
chemical scalding his skin as the same
black ooze burn through his clothing and
started to singe his chest another hand
shot forward out of the puddle on the
wall a clawed thumb puncturing avi's
side he screamed in pain as he felt the
blistering digit Pierce into him while
the rest of the fingers pulled him
closer still to the wall using the hole
in his side like a handle the stench of
his own burning flesh mixed with the air
of rotting Decay that scp-106 brought
with it everywhere the decaying face of
the old man peered through the black
slime on the wall its mouth locked in a
sadistic Sinister grin as Avi found
himself pulled inside it almost felt
like he had fallen asleep in the bathtub
and woke up gasping and sputtering just
having narrowly avoided drowning except
now he was waking up in an entirely
different space the transition there
having done little to deal the pain of
his injuries sitting up as he arrived in
his new dark and desolate surroundings
Avi gripped his side and winced at the
Searing pain then the sun smell of
burning plastic crawled up his nostrils
and downed the back of his throat most
of the equipment the foundation had
strapped onto him was melting the heart
rate monitor and Camera corroding
covered in more of that black sludge
standing up gritting his teeth through
the pain of his wounds Avi quickly
removed the devices as carefully as he
could it was far beyond caring about the
foundation's Expedition right now he
just wanted to get back out of wherever
the hell this place was checking over
his shoulder the Slick corrosive puddle
he'd been pulled through was already
gone at any rate Avi didn't particularly
like the idea of going back that way so
was relieved although he'd soon find out
that relief was perhaps misplaced he had
barely a few moments to examine his
surroundings not that there was much he
could see besides endless dark corridors
and the withered figure of the old man
it had reappeared looking like it was
far off in the distance before in a
split second the gap between
scp-106 and Avi had closed the creature
tilted its bald skeletal head as it
looked at him and he got a full
unobscured Glimpse at its sunken eyes
and face locked in a Perpetual lipless
grin the rotting wrinkly flesh of the
old man's body was oozing more and more
of that dark disgusting mucus droplets
of it landing on avi's clothing and
burning holes right through one hand
still applying pressure to his side I'll
be turned and tried to run as far and
fast as his body was able if getting
away was his sole objective he wanted
out as quick as possible anything to get
away from the nightmarish creature he
had now found himself trapped with
running didn't seem to work though he
was sure he had made it at least a few
feet the old man was still standing
behind him but looked to be at more of a
distance that was until Avi noticed his
legs they were running backwards each
step he had taken away from scp-106 was
being reversed rewound like on an old
VHS tape bringing him back closer and
closer to the creature's clutches its
claws pushed painfully through avi's
back as It reversed time right back to
the point where he had turned to run
away as the old man reached through him
more of that burn acidic pain started
eating away at its captive d-class prey
with Avi letting out a pain scream it
wasn't until several minutes in that he
realized something that hurt almost just
as bad
scp-106 could have killed him in an
instant that much was clear but it
hadn't it had chosen not to instead it
was torturing him prolonging the pain
Avi was experiencing because it wanted
him to suffer with all its strength
scp-106 hurled him several feet until
avi's burning corroded body collided
with a hard surface a wall with a loud
crack the old man then manipulated time
within his pocket Dimension causing Avi
to fly backward through the air back
into the creature's corrosive grip it
allowed time to keep winding back
undoing all the damage it had done so
far as much as Avi was relieved to be
rid of the Searing pain he was in a sick
worry deep in the pit of his stomach
told him that this wasn't an act of
Mercy the old man just wanted to make
him suffer all over again he lost track
of how long it went on for
scp-106 taking sickly and hurting his
captive only to reverse the time within
the pocket Dimension and do it all again
each time felt just like the first made
worse by the fact that Avi never had a
chance to get used to the pain to become
numb to it instead every moment the
torture started was just like the first
time in fact it technically was
screaming in agony Avi had no clue if he
had been there for hours days months or
even years had any time passed at all
how many times had the old man done this
to him only to reverse time and do it
all over again letting the pain begin
Anew every few tries the old man would
release Avi for a moment but once again
it was never done out of any sense of
Mercy or kindness it was so it could
hunt him still Avi ran every time as far
and fast as he could searching every
corner of that dark desolate place for
some kind of a way out a portal home
another one of those corrosive black
puddles a big door with exit written on
it in big letters but instead all he
found was
scp-106 or rather the old man found him
it was hunting him again Avi had no idea
how many times this made panting he
slowed to a halt trying to catch his
breath reaching out in the dark he put a
hand against a nearby hard surface a
wall then felt a crack under his hand
examining closer although he could
barely see it Javi could feel with
absolute certainty that this wall had
been damaged just a little it was the
same one the exact same wall he had been
thrown against who knew how long ago but
the point was it was still cracked from
where his body had hit it even after the
old man had reversed time to hurt Avi
over and over again the damage had
stayed he had no way of knowing if it
would work or how long it would take but
it might have been a way out desperately
Avi slammed his fist against the wall
feeling pain shooting through his
fingers and up into his arm as it
collided with a solid surface nothing
changed winding back the other arm he
hid it again still nothing Avi could
hear the old man shuffling closer behind
him could sense his hands reaching out
closer to torture him again he let it
happen striking one last blow against
the wall before it finally reached him
and the pain began once more only to be
reversed so that
scp-106 could do it again but now he had
a goal each time the creature rewound
time and undid all the damage to its
captive's body Avi went looking for that
same wall feeling across every surface
until he reached it again the damage was
still there only a tiny crack for now
but time despite being under the old
man's control in this pocket Dimension
was on avi's side whenever he made it
back to the wall he started to punch it
again pounding one fist against it after
the other he didn't relent despite the
pain it caused him he told himself it
would be worth it if it meant a way out
even the times when the bones in his
hands broke and he was flimsily striking
at the cracked wall with shattered
fingers he didn't stop it would be worth
it it had to be no matter how long it
took he would gradually chip away at the
wall more and more every time scp-106
would find Avi and when it did it would
hurt him the pain he'd put himself
through trying to break down the wall
helped numb some of the torture before
the old man reset everything
then the hunt began again and Avi went
back to making his gradual dent in the
wall the whole time he remembered he was
doing it for Kali for his freedom and a
fresh start until eventually it stopped
Avi had no idea how many times he'd
struck the wall but it had been enough
to Start Tumbling through it slightly
both hands bloody and broken again but
this time the old man didn't appear it
had stopped screaming in Rage Avi
started throwing himself at the indented
wall trying desperately to Chip Away
more completely unaware that scp-106 had
left him alone in its pocket Dimension
back in their facility the foundation
had lost contact with avi's recording
devices over three hours ago at which
point they had initiated their recall
protocol injuring the d-class they had
chosen as a lure sure enough the old man
had reappeared from his pocket Dimension
following the pain screams to come and
finish the lure off there was no sign of
Avi and with a sign the head researcher
simply noted down as cp106 pocket
Dimension Escape test result test
inconclusive I made it I actually made
it I'm still alive by some miracle or
maybe by sheer luck I made it to the end
of my sentence over three months of the
most horrific work I've ever had to do
with no other alternative but it's paid
off because any minute now they'll be
coming into the dorm to let me go I can
walk out of here with my head up I can't
wait to get out of these orange overalls
that I've had to live in since I arrived
it seems like so much longer in all
honesty the only way I've been able to
keep track of how many days I've been
stuck here is by putting tally marks on
the wall next to my dormitory bed
100. I've been a member of d-class
personnel for the sap foundation for the
last 100 days and here's how I survived
they didn't waste any time early on I'll
give the foundation that I'd barely been
out of my sentencing hearing for a few
days put on trial and convicted for a
crime I didn't even commit or been a
string of murders and someone who had
either been involved or was responsible
people laid the blame on me but whoever
they were they had powerful friends the
cops were in on it planting evidence to
frame me and make me look like I was
guilty when I was really innocent that's
what landed me in prison serving a
sentence of 25 years to Life Behind Bars
and it was during my first week of
incarceration that he showed up the
recruitment specialist a clean-cut blunt
agent Smith type came to visit me I'd
even been in prison long enough to have
visitor privileges but the Shady agents
seemed to know which strings to pull in
order to ask me an important question
what would you do to get out of here
you'd said to which my answer was
anything that was my first mistake
immediately the next day I received a
letter detailing more about what exactly
agent Smith was offering it was folded
and hidden in the spine of a book that a
guard handed me during reading hour
unfolding the message it all felt like
an old school covert spy tactic to Mr
Emil conquer the letter red we
understand that you've recently received
a criminal convict
there are two options currently before
you as detailed below one you can serve
out the remainder of your sentence in
prison or two you can be released into
the care of our organization while with
us you will be helping to further
scientific advancements through hard
work we've devised A system that allows
convicts such as yourself to perform a
vital role within our organization in a
return for a reduction in their prison
sentences we have no interest in or
intention of determining any guilt for
the crimes for which you are currently
convicted we merely seek to present this
opportunity for you we ask that you
destroy this ladder once you have
finished reading should you be
interested in our offer then please
recite the phrase it's a yes to a prison
guard with the badge number
47890 naturally as crypto can offer like
that was I didn't need much time to mull
it over I was trapped in prison for
something I didn't do with no way to
appeal for my freedom or prove my
innocence so taking up a mysterious job
opportunity from a shadowy group seem
like a much better alternative at the
time after all I could either work off
my sentence through employment or rot
Away In A Cell for the next two and a
half decades at minimum all I had to do
next was find the Right Guard I tried
not to make it obvious that I was eyeing
every prison guard's badge number as
they stood around keeping a close eye on
me and the other inmates but it was
while I was out in the yard that I saw
him number 47890 I'd gone to bed with a
knot in my stomach hours earlier I had
done exactly as the letter said and
approached the guard making sure I was
close enough for him to hear me but
trying to make it clear that I wasn't
looking to start any trouble either it's
a yes I told him in response 47890 had
furrowed his brow and scrunched his
mustache seemingly in discussed back up
inmate he commanded sharply I backed
away with my hands raised confused as to
what just happened I spent the entire
rest of the day thinking about it maybe
the note had been a prank some kind of
initiation seeing as I was the newest
prisoner but that didn't explain the
agent who had shown up before what was
going on questions that were spinning
around in my head eventually wore me out
and while I slept that's when someone
put a bag over my head drugged me and
snuck me out of prison when I woke up I
was somewhere new a room filled with
other convicts although not many of them
seem to have come from the same prison I
have been sentenced to plenty were
sporting different jumpsuits but their
Gruff demeanors told me all I needed
about them I was surrounded by a more
violent breed of criminal some of the
worst of the absolute worst the
atmosphere in this pen full of murders
and monsters was so tense that it felt
like the slightest accidental bump could
explode into a full-blown fight suddenly
a hatch in the ceiling opened and a pile
of clothing came thumping down from
above it was a massive orange enough
matching overalls for every inmate in
the room of course I held back from the
initial clamor some of the others made
grabbing their new prison guard
snatching orange overalls from each
other and arguing when I eventually got
mine I noticed an unfamiliar logo
emblazoned on the front of the uniform
after being made to wait a whole day in
the pen the other prisoners and I were
filed out of the room by heavily armed
security guards we were all directed
towards a hall nobody was daring enough
to challenge the officers even the more
violent among the prisoners I spotted
that the guards uniforms bore the same
Insignia as the overalls we'd been made
to wear must have been the logo of the
mysterious organization that had offered
me employment we were given an
orientation talk led by someone who
introduced themselves as a junior
assistant researcher they explained that
our current location was highly
classified as was the true identity of
the group that had a range for us to be
released all we were told was that this
was an unspecified form of research
facility and that we had to cooperate
with the facility staff if we wanted to
secure our release it seems
straightforward enough although the
junior assistant researchers seemed to
make a lot of jokes about us dying
during these tests I think they hoped it
would alleviate some of the tension it
didn't after sitting through the
orientation talk I still had more
questions than answers the one thing I
had Learned was that being tattoo dude
hurt exiting the hall the other
prisoners and I had been directed to get
a designation number tattooed on our
wrist and across our chest when someone
had asked why the chest the researcher
conducting orientation had answered well
in the events of an explosion it's most
likely that it will be the largest
intact chunk of meat left this was
another one of their jokes still feeling
sore as my tattoo healed I read the
number now permanently Inked onto my
body
d2152 d-class Personnel that's what they
call the snail we were directed into a
dormitory a lot less cramped than my old
cell but still being surrounded by
violent criminals when I knew I didn't
belong there it felt no less isolating
one of them who took the bunk next to
mine introduced himself to me as shiv
where'd he might try to kill me I did my
best to be friendly towards him shiv and
I didn't exactly Bond but more sprung up
conversations because there was little
else to do I was still worried about
some of the Flippin comments made about
all of us dying until he pointed out
some thing far stranger don't you wonder
why they're making us all wait he asked
and the moment he mentioned it I did
start to wonder about that it seemed odd
that this organization had wasted little
time in getting us all here it only been
a week ago that I entered my prison cell
for the first time and now I was here I
think it's their way of telling us [__]
went on that we aren't here to be
helpful to be a Workforce for them they
brought us all here to die that comment
made me look around and actually
acknowledge the people I was trapped
with they were some of the worst
criminals imaginable irredeemable
Killers would this organization really
let those people back out into the world
after helping out with a few tests I'd
soon find out because day eight was the
last before I found myself working
directly for the SCP Foundation I picked
up the name from a few places around the
facility name tags lab coats and
security uniforms always with the same
logo me and the other d-class Personnel
were woken up early in the morning by a
bell and issued with assignments for the
very first day the works started I
noticed that not all the others came
back to the dorm at the end of the day
shiv was one of those my tasks mostly
consisted of cleaning up with a mop
hosing down empty testing chambers that
had a worrying amount of blood sprayed
all over the walls and Floors the
regiments were strict and I made sure to
do exactly what was asked of me to avoid
causing any trouble it felt like a lot
like being back in prison but with the
only added caveat of being able to move
around the facility even if it was to go
and wipe up the foundation's mess
although the other classes of personnel
didn't seem to take kindly to my help
making snide comments as they pass me in
the hallways we've been told not to
address the other staff unless spoken to
which was frustrating I certainly had a
few things I would have liked to say to
them after two and a half weeks without
so much as a hint of any trouble I was
given my first testing assignment that
wasn't just cleaning up you would think
that would be exciting but having seen
some of the Carnage Left Behind after
other tests I was anything but eager to
take part luckily for me and pretty
surprisingly my first test was pretty
straightforward I was shown to a room
containing a white bowl decorated with
light blue flowers that researchers
referred to as
scp-348 I received a nasty splinter from
my MOX handle the day before and was
instructed to sit down and eat from the
bowl which was filled with soup
naturally I eagerly ate it despite how
bitter it tasted it was better than the
food from The d-class Canteen at least
but when I finished I noticed a message
had appeared at the bottom of scp-348 it
read I don't believe you were framed
goodbye son after that it was as if the
floodgates had been opened and every day
I was asked to do another test with a
new SCP most were harmless anomalous
creatures or objects like one of the
bigger experiments I was involved in
which focused on scp-999 this friendly
little gelatinous orange blob electrodes
were hooked up to me while I just calmly
sat in a room with scp-999 being around
it made me feel great the best I'd felt
since arriving and joining d-class
although I did hear one of the other
researchers making a comment that
scp-999 was quote not ready yet whatever
that meant even so the Tickle Monster
had given me a new positive outlook on
my role at the foundation it was odd
work but I could find a rhythm to it
that would hopefully make the time pass
by a little quicker and if it meant
getting out it was worth all the dirty
looks from other classes of personnel
this was an Outlook I didn't want to
lose after a month we were told to take
a pill that the guards handed out to us
something called an amnestic that would
make us all forget the previous month
but wanting to hang on to my newfound
optimism I secretly flush mine down a
toilet in hindsight I should have taken
it my next big test quickly brought me
down a peg I was handed to Katana
scp-572 and instantly felt like I was
Unstoppable the sword made me believe I
was a powerful Warrior if I could maybe
fight my way out of the foundation
facility with ease unfortunately the
moment I tried to use it didn't lead to
freedom I had an accident broke my arm
and suffered series of internal
fractures all while the research team
mocked me embarrassed and I felt like a
total laughing stock things only got
worse from there I'd barely set foot
outside of the infirmary before a
different team of personnel told me I
was going to be assisting them with an
important task they dragged me to an old
wooden door after briefly explaining
what was going on although I struggled
to keep up Beyond the Door which they
called
scp-2317 was a vast salt plane following
their instructions I acted as an
assistant to the rest of the team as
they performed a strange ritual I had to
scatter a mix of holy water and chicken
blood around a circle of Seven Stone
pillars then recycled blood for the old
gods water for the new king it was an
unusual practice to say the least but
apparently I was helping keep a powerful
vengeful demigod imprisoned that did
little to soften the news that I heard
when we returned through
scp-2317 when I was gone one of the
foundation's security team had been
infected by something known as SC
p2193 a phenomenon that makes people
believe that every month a large group
of d-class are to be terminated when I
heard I actually considered taking my
amnestic for this month to forget just
how many had been killed it had been a
whole two months since I had actively
started work as part of d-class
personnel and there weren't many of my
fellow prisoners left I was sent for a
mandatory psychological evaluation the
foundation wanted to know if I would
still be able to perform tests for them
I doubted it came from a place of actual
concern it's not like they cared all
that much if the things I had seen were
taking a toll on me sitting across from
a researcher performing my evaluation I
did my best impression of a normal
person I had to pretend like none of it
was getting to me all the horrors and
the close brush I'd almost had with
death by monthly termination I wouldn't
have lied about it normally but I'd been
told I had a month left before I was due
to be released apparently not many
d-class made it that far given the
dangerous nature of testing all I could
think about was how good it would feel
to eat real food again I started to
daydream about getting a cheeseburger on
my first day out almost instantly my
hopes of Freedom were dashed the very
next day I was told I'd be going on a
longer assignment this time it would be
an expedition into an anomalous location
called
scp-432 the foundation researchers
outfitted me with a flashlight plus
extra batteries a headset and a
microphone linked to their control
center were placed over my ear along
with a camera unit mounted on my
shoulder they said it would wirelessly
transmit back to them and they'd see
what I saw I was also given a couple
bottles of water some energy bars and a
few sticks of luminous marker chalk but
when they had said anomalous location
the last thing I'd been expecting was to
climb into a rusty metal cabinet the
next two weeks were like living inside a
nightmare inside the cabinet was a huge
maze a literal Labyrinth all made out of
the same rusted steel of the exterior of
scp-432 it was so dark even with the use
of my flashlight and the few light bulbs
affixed to some of the Walls Within the
cabinet mace before long I ended up
losing my bearings and lost with no way
out but being trapped in the Maze and
the dark wasn't even the worst part
there was something else in the
Labyrinth some kind of creature lurking
through the metal corridors my
flashlight eventually ran out of power
so I never actually saw it but every
time I tried to sleep I just lay awake
listening to its growls I couldn't help
but think what kind of horrible thing
was out there and might be looming over
me in the dark even when I opened my
eyes I still wouldn't get to see it
eventually another d-class was sent into
scp-432 by some miracle he was able to
not only find me but guide me back to
the entrance of the cabinet mace the
moment I was free I yelled at the
research team demanding they let me go I
didn't just mean let out of scp-432 I
meant free from d-class from the
foundation from all of it I was sent for
another psyche evaluation and deemed to
be fine just suffering from heightened
stress when they had asked me if I'd
been taking my amnestics I lied and I
told them yes 10 days before I was set
to be released and they couldn't help
but assign me to one last test don't
worry a researcher sarcastically assured
me this one will be nice and easy on you
you just have to jump into a paddling
pool you can do that can't you d2152 the
paddling pool in question was scp-120
every time a different glow emanated
from it I was instructed to jump into it
the exact second I did I found myself
transported somewhere new I got the
Himalayas on my first go Greenland and
the Sahara desert on the next two tries
every one of the locations I ended up at
had some kind of foundation facility
established nearby they'd pick me up and
I'd be taken right back to scp-120 to
continue testing it felt like I was
being deliberately intentionally
tortured the foundation was giving me
these momentary glimpses of Freedom
every time I was transported by scp-120
was a carrot on the end of the stick
that they were keeping just out of my
reach and I hated it it made me realize
that I had never been there to work for
them being part of d-class personnel
wasn't a job all I I was to them was a
human lab rat but now it's my last day
it promised me by the end of day today I
wouldn't be here anymore I just want to
be out done with d-class for good the
foundation researchers have given me one
last simple test to do before I go they
said if I do then I'll be gone all they
wanted me to do is wear this amulet for
someone named Dr bright how hard can
that be and they said they let me go
after this one thing so can't be
anything that bad right right want to
own an SCP of your own go to scpswag.com
for premius anomalous merchandise now go
and check out what if stars are actually
exploding d-class
scp-2193 and scp-2317 the Devourer of
Worlds adore to another world for more
strange stories taken from the ranks of
the SCP Foundation